Guten Morgen Linus. So Linus, mir ist ein bisschen kalt.
Guten Morgen Tim. Ja ich habe die Heizung auch schon ausgemacht.
Logbuch-Netzpolitik Nummer 426 vom 1. April. Und den Aspekt habe ich noch gar nicht nachgedacht. Ersten April zwanzig zweiundzwanzig
Ja und heute kommt die Wahrheit und nichts als die Wahrheit.
Ich habe gestern schon auf Twitter versprochen, äh vorgestern auf Twitter versprochen, dass wir am Donnerstag aufnehmen und jetzt hast du zugegeben, dass wir nochmal umgeschoben haben den Termin.
Na ja, komm. Man muss auch transparent sein, oder? Wir fordern nochmal Transparenz. Ja. Und jetzt sind wir transparent und sagen.
Wir müssen zugeben, dass wir tief in den äh Krieg gegen die Ukraine verwickelt sind. Also der Krieg der Ukraine gegen den Krieg.
Die Heizung runtergedreht haben.
Nee, wir haben da ja eigene Leute an Bord. Die Einhornstandarte.
Das stimmt. Ich bin ja komplett ins Essen gefallen. Ähm einer unserer Hörerinnen hat das äh zugeschickt.
Es gibt da tatsächlich eine Einhornstandarte. Ich habe keine Ahnung, was die bedeutet. Ich packe mal das Foto mit in die Shownotes rein, aber es sieht grandios aus.
Oder? Also sie haben so einen so ukrainische Soldaten, die so ein Einhorn Wappen tragen.
Da kann man auch was draus machen. Wenn man nicht schon so ein schönes hätten, äh so eine schöne Visualisierung, würde ich fast sagen. Na ja, okay, keine.
Ja wir haben.
Wissen nicht, was das wieder für eine Gruppe ist, ja, falls wir uns jetzt hier irgendeinen.
Ein Messaging äh vorwirft, wenn später rauskommt, dass das so ganz schlimme Schweinereien sind, die da gemacht werden, wissen wir nicht. Wir haben nur diese Fotos gesehen und dachten so, oh schöne Einhorn. So einfach sind wir gestrickt.
Zum Thema äh Ukraine wollen wir uns ja insgesamt äh ein bisschen.
Zurückhalten, weil ihr ohnehin mit diesem Thema die ganze Zeit geflutet werdet auf allen Nachrichtenkanälen und sicher jetzt auch alle meinen, dazu äußern zu müssen. Wir konzentrieren uns ein bisschen auf ähm.
Ja, bleiben bei unseren bei unseren Kernthemen.
Wie auch sonst immer.
Ich würde aber gerne ähm.
Ja, ein bisschen berichten, was ich hier in Berlin so in letzter Zeit ähm erlebt habe oder beobachtet habe, paar Sachen.
Gemacht habe, paar Sachen gesehen habe, das ist ja schon eine sehr ähm beeindruckende ähm Welle der Solidarität, die da jetzt stattfindet. Ähm.
Teilweise stellt man sich die Frage, warum die bei Geflüchteten aus anderen Ländern ähm anders verläuft, diese Solidarität. Ähm.
Das äh kann man natürlich auch ein bisschen kritisch beäugen, aber im Moment hier in Berlin, es war so eine so eine Situation, da war ich ähm im Straßenverkehr unterwegs und sah auf einmal so ein absolut,
dreckigen Golf. Ja, so ein Golf Kombi. Der war so scheiße dreckig, dass ich selbst ich als Radfahrer dachte, Junge.
So kannst du doch nicht rumfahren, du musst mal dein Auto putzen. Ja Deutsche Mentalität so Samstag, du kannst dich am Samstag mit so einem Auto rumfahren.
Da habe ich echt so gedacht, boah, ist das ein dreckiges Auto, da kann man ja als Nummernschild noch nicht mal erkennen. Und habe dann ähm gesehen, je mehr, also beim Versuch, das Nummernschild zu erkennen, dass da eben ein ukrainisches dran war
und da habe ich ja doch mal so einen kurzen Moment ist es ja dann echt äh äh so ein kalter Schauer den Rücken runter gelaufen, weil ich halt wusste, okay warum dieses Fahrzeug so aussieht und welche Strecke das wohl
äh zurückgelegt hat in um dort jetzt grade im im Stau an der Oberbaumbrücke zu stehen.
Und ähm ja sind in Berlin fällt einem das relativ häufig auf äh so Fahrzeuge mit diesen Kennzeichen. Ähm auch Menschen, die sich dann an den an den unterschiedlichsten ähm,
ja Zentren treffen, die irgendwie einerseits offiziell, aber auch von ähm ja von,
Gruppen errichtet wurden, wo dann war ich bei so einem ja ukrainischen Begegnungsabend, wo dann eben viele,
ukrainische Geflüchtete waren und viele Menschen, die hier in Berlin wohnen, nicht notwendigerweise jetzt Deutsche oder so, die dann da äh gemeinsam kochen und so ähm,
so unterschiedliche so wie wie nennt man das denn? So einfach so so.
Tafel Whiteboards quasi stehen, wo irgendwie so Biete Suche, ja, so kann helfen bei äh und dann da einfach so diese.
Sich gegenseitig helfen, ne? Oder äh Dinge, Dinge gemeinsam machen. Das war im im Moos so ein Projekt in der Moosdorfer Straße in Berlin, wo ich sehr,
auch selber beeindruckend finde, die dann da sich, ne, sofort bereit.
Stellen und sagen, hier da müssen die Menschen sind ja jetzt hier alleine, die müssen ja irgendwie einen Kontakt finden zueinander und einen sozialen Anschluss und so, dass das einfach so aus den ganzen ja zivilen.
Initiativen irgendwie aus,
allem Möglichen kommt, ja, nicht notwendigerweise linke Gruppierungen nicht notwendigerweise sonst irgendwas, sondern dass die Leute einfach sagen, okay, was kann ich denn jetzt grade mal so machen?
Das hat mich schon sehr äh begeistert oder beeindruckt, was da so war und ähm.
Sehr äh beeindruckt hat mich auch.
Guter Freund von mir der sich gerade eigentlich mal besser freut, der sich gerade eine neue Wohnung gemietet hat.
Und ähm mit dem Beginn des Krieges hatte er diese Wohnung jetzt fertig eingerichtet und war bereit da einzuziehen und ähm.
Kamen eben diese ja auf den zivilen Kanälen, auf den nicht auf den ad hoc organisierten Kanälen eben die suchen nach Orten und Wohnungen und Plätzen, wo Geflüchtete unterkommen können.
Der hat einfach mal spontan gesagt, ja äh die Wohnung ist fertig ähm da kann man so einziehen.
Hm dann ziehe ich jetzt halt beim Kumpel in eine WG für ein paar Monate und stelle die Wohnung bereit. Und ähm gleichzeitig ähm.
Irgendwie sein beim seinem Job die Arbeitszeit reduziert, sodass er das jetzt ehrlich gesagt eigentlich gar nicht unbedingt finanziell stemmen kann.
Und ja, fände ich halt eine äh Spitzenaktion, also er kann's finanziell stemmen, aber er muss dann halt aus seinem Ersparten das finanzieren. Also habe ich gesagt, nee, das geht so nicht, also zahle ich mal die Miete.
Und ähm jetzt habe ich mir überlegt, warum soll ich das eigentlich zahlen? Es gibt ja genug Leute, die vielleicht mitbezahlen möchten und dann kann man das wieder auf mehr Schultern verteilen.
Erste Monat ist ja jetzt rum mit dem 1. April und wir machen mal einen kleinen äh Infos in die Shownotes,
meinem besten Freund dabei helfen wollt, äh die Miete zu bezahlen für die Wohnung, die er jetzt für die Geflüchteten zur Verfügung stellt, mit denen Menschen, äh die da wohnen ähm,
natürlich auch äh irre Erfahrungen gemacht, also.
Geschichten, die die so erzählen können, ähm gehen natürlich echt unter die Haut. Ähm ja die haben auch so ein dreckiges Auto.
Vier Tage sind die gefahren.
Aus der Ukraine nach Berlin. Drei Tage im Stau durch die Ukraine. Ähm und dann eben kurz durch Polen, dann waren sie in Berlin.
Mhm. Und sind natürlich sehr äh.
Dankbar, herzlich, freundlich und ähm auch irgendwie voller Bemühungen irgendwie in diesem in diesem Land jetzt Fuß zu fassen.
Das wird vermutlich nicht für alle besonders einfach sein und das äh finde ich auch ein bisschen äh belastend.
Umso irre, was was einem dann da halt auch für eine äh Gastfreundschaft.
Und ähm meine Herzlichkeit entgegenkommt. Ähm müssen die wollen jetzt andauernd kochen. Wir müssen da jetzt immer hin und essen, ja. Ähm.
Ja und äh das hat mich äh dann doch sehr über diese Situation zum ähm Nachdenken gebracht, wie da.
Über diese Menschen hereingebrochen ist und das äh ist ja schon ähm.
Ja nachhaltig zum Kotzen, was äh da den Menschen widerfährt.
Gleichzeitig die Wohnung da wechseln auch teilweise die Besetzung, also galt so tragisch oder ganz so schlecht scheint es auch nicht zu sein, weil wenn die Besetzung wechselt und die Menschen irgendwie weiterziehen, heißt das ja, dass sie irgendwelche,
stabileren Formen, besseren Formen, Anschlusspunkte gefunden haben. Insofern scheint das auch ein,
in gewisser Form von Erfolg gekrönt zu sein, weil es ja auch quasi jetzt nicht,
also es ist ja nicht die Idee, dass sie jetzt äh dauerhaft dort wohnen, sondern die wollen ja auch
irgendwie sich wieder etwas aufbauen ähm und ein Leben führen, indem sie einen gesellschaftlichen Beitrag leisten können, aus dem sie herausgerissen wurden, ne, aus aus,
Job aus.
Ja Leben, sozialen Gefügen, in denen sie sich teilweise seit Jahrzehnten wohl gefühlt haben und auch äh verankert waren, stehen sie jetzt halt mit einer mit einem Koffer in Berlin und wissen nicht, wie's weitergeht. Insofern,
Also meine höchste Anerkennung für Tobi, dass er das gemacht hat und deswegen würde ich mich über Unterstützung freuen.
Da findet ihr dann die passenden Links in den dazu.
Genau. Äh hast du den Jingle noch die gute Nachricht?
Klar, habe ich. Haben wir eine?
Ich würde sagen ja.
Wir haben im Dezember ja schon drüber gesprochen, dass ähm sich andeutet, dass der Münchner Hersteller von.
Staatlich staatlicher Überwachungssoftware,
Pleite geht, nämlich Finn Fischer, das ich nenne das jetzt mal Unternehmenskonglomerat, die haben da andauernd neu gegründet. Ganz früher hießen sie Magamma, dann gab's die Finnfischer Labs und haste alles nicht gesehen.
Edaman und was nicht alles äh
lange Rede, kurzer Sinn, die scheinen tatsächlich pleite zu sein. Wir hatten ja ursprünglich äh im Dezember darüber gesprochen, dass es,
nach einem ähm Hütchenspiel aussieht, aber ähm Andre Meister hat von einer internen Quelle dort,
ähm den so eine Nachricht bekommen sinngemäß äh Finn Fischer ist Pleite ähm wird jetzt geschlossen und bleibt es auch, ihr solltet feiern,
ihr habt gewonnen solche Nachrichten liest man ja gerne,
Und ähm André hat das Thema noch mal ein bisschen genauer auseinandergenommen. Dann warum sind die denn eigentlich insolvent gegangen? Und da müssen wir vielleicht nochmal die ganze Geschichte ähm von Beginn an erzählen.
Und zwar ähm.
Hat sich ja, wenn ich mich nicht täusche, so 2017 die ersten Anzeichen ergeben oder dass das Finnfischer in der Türkei gegen die Opposition eingesetzt wurde.
Und dann gab es ähm diese,
diese Sample, also ein Sample, ist quasi eine in der in der freien Wildbahn gefundene Variante der Schadsoftware.
Wurde ähm analysiert und dabei kam raus.
Dass dieses Sample ähm erstens Finnfischer ist, das muss man ja auch erstmal nachweisen und zweitens, dass es nach einem bestimmten Datum hergestellt wurde
und dadurch, dass es nach diesem Datum hergestellt wurde, ist es eine ähm,
ist quasi bewiesen, dass es nach Inkrafttreten von Exportkontrollen für Finnfischer,
erstellt wurde, also Situation, es gibt Exportkontrollen, es wird etwas gegen die türkische Opposition eingesetzt und ähm.
Der Beweis ist er erbracht oder der Verdacht besteht, dass es quasi nach diesem Inkrafttreten der Exportkontrollen.
Erzeugt wurde mit anderen Worten, es gibt den Verdacht des Verstoßes gegen Exportkontrollen.
Also Ausfuge ohne Ausfuhrgenehmigung in die Türkei exportiert zu haben. Ähm jetzt muss man natürlich sagen, so Exportkontrollen, die funktionieren bei Panzern super, ja, weil die Panzer kriegst du halt echt schwer ausm Land.
Software,
weniger schwierig, ne? Also wir haben alle Internet. Wir wissen, dass es da eigentlich keine Grenzen gibt und es ist jetzt nicht so einfach nachzuweisen, ähm dass etwas wirklich von überhaupt diesem einen Unternehmen stammt.
Es wurde dann 20019 im Juli würde ich jetzt sagen, wenn ich mich nicht täusche,
eine Strafanzeige erstattet gegen Finnfischer,
von Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte, Reporter ohne Grenzen, URC European Center forstitutional and Human Rights, also ECCHR und Netzpolitik ORG. Die haben diese Strafanzeige gestellt.
Und dann ist aber erstmal sehr lange überhaupt nichts passiert.
Dann ähm hatte mich der Ulf Buhrmeier schon gefragt, ob wir nicht als CCC,
dieses Sample auch nochmal anschauen und quasi eine,
tiefergehende Analyse nachliefern um den Verdacht noch einmal zu erhärten um quasi auch die staatlichen Stellen, bei denen die Anzeige die Strafanzeige gestellt wurde ähm zum Handeln zu bewegen.
Das äh habe ich dann Thorsten gefragt, Thorsten Schröder, ob der das mit mir zusammen machen möchte, ähm hat eigentlich auch sehr viel zu tun, aber er hat's sich hat's getan und es war eine.
Ein paar Monate Arbeit, äh die dann im in der beim.
Letzten CCC-Kongress, also 2 Dezember 20019 veröffentlicht wurde und wir haben,
So ein bisschen das Ding mit Thorsten, der kann Sachen nicht einfach mal nur so ein bisschen machen. Ja, der muss dann immer vom vom 10 ins Tausendste
Komplett zerrissen hat, ja und so haben wir dann nicht nur dieses eine Sample analysiert,
sondern ähm ich glaube, das waren 28 Versionen und die Idee dieser 28 Versionen zu analysieren, ist eben,
oder der der Hauptpunkt war, den die in einer die gefundene Version von Finnfischer in eine Evolution abzubilden der verschiedenen Finn-Fisher-Samples, um nicht nur um um quasi auch,
der Ausrede zu begegnen, dass hier irgendjemand vielleicht finnischer gestohlen hätte oder so, sondern eben zu sagen, das ist ähm hat quasi Code.
Ähnlichkeiten, mit Versionen von zwanzigvierzehn und Versionen von zwanzig achtzehn, neunzehn, um das Ding quasi in die komplette Entwicklungshistorie des Unternehmens einzubetten und so quasi den den,
den Verdacht einfach vollständig einzuschnüren, das kommt von euch, ja.
Hatten wir ohnehin keinen Zweifel dran, aber sowas muss dann natürlich mal ähm also wenn du wenn du möchtest, dass jemand eine Strafe bekommt, dann muss das natürlich,
durchziehen. Dann wurde diese die Analyse haben wir genau zum Kongress dann veröffentlicht und ähm dann gab es noch verschiedene Treffen mit dem Zollkriminalamt und der,
Staatsanwaltschaft München, in denen der Thorsten dann auch nochmal alles erklärt hat. Wir haben ja auch so Analyse-Tools veröffentlicht und unsere unsere,
war ja damals zu Adam, soll doch bitte das BKA hingehen und
die Analyse an ihrem eigenen Trojaner machen, dann sehen sie ja, dass es Finn Fischer ist, ja, weil die haben den ja auch. Die sind ja Kunden, was natürlich auch vielleicht eine anfängliche Zögerlichkeit gegen dieses Unternehmen
vorzugehen erklären könnte.
Spannenderweise gab es dann ähm im Oktober zwanzig zwanzig.
Endlich Durchsuchungen bei Gamma Finn Fischer und das, die hatten's ja echt in sich, das waren ähm ich glaube an zehn5 Orten.
Mich nicht täusche, 15 Wohn- und Geschäftsräume im In und Ausland, also sind richtig internationaler Schlag, der dann da durchgeführt wurde und dann hörte man wieder nichts.
Was ihr jetzt quasi was andere ähm herausgefunden hat, ist ähm.
Die Staatsanwaltschaft hat dann offenbar eine ähm ein Vermögensarrest.
Äh eingeleitet, wo also gesagt wird, okay, wir frieren euer Vermögen ein, weil der Verdacht besteht, dass ihr das widerrechtlich erlangt habt.
Und damit wollen wir verhindern, dass ihr dieses ähm Vermögen jetzt ausgebt oder außer Landes bringt, damit wir es nämlich gegebenenfalls einziehen können. Also das ist.
Ernster Verdacht, ja? Also ich meine, dass sie,
15 Wohn- und Geschäftsräume durchsuchen, ist schon ein ziemlicher Verdacht, aber wenn Sie dann sagen, ey sag mal, die Cola auf dem Konto, da machen wir jetzt mal lieber ein Vermögensarest, das passiert schon, würde ich mal vermuten, nicht so schnell.
Diesen Vermögensarest.
Ist ähm das Unternehmen jetzt durch Insolvenz entgangen. Also die haben gesagt, okay wir wir das Unternehmen ist insolvent. Wir können ja sowieso nicht mehr agieren, wenn wir in unter wenn wir ein Vermögensarest haben, weil wir haben kein Geld mehr um irgendetwas zu bezahlen,
Gleichzeitig können sie damit aber natürlich nicht dem Strafverfahren entkommen. Das läuft natürlich weiter gegen die Verantwortlichen. Also.
Es sieht gerade echt ganz gut aus. Erstens, dass diese Menschen eine äh Strafe bekommen und ähm eben auch, dass dieses Unternehmen erledigt.
Kann man sich natürlich fragen, na ja, machen die nicht vielleicht doch einfach nur irgendeinen Trick und haben den Code außer Landes geschafft oder sonst was. Ja, das ist, da besteht immer noch ein dünner.
Ein schmale Wahrscheinlichkeit, aber wenn die Verantwortlichen verknackt werden für den Verstoß gegen Exportkontrollen.
Das wirklich für die am Horizont ist dann wären sie schon echt höchst kriminell,
und auch wahrscheinlich nicht gut beraten, wenn sie versuchen würden, diesen Code jetzt auch noch weiter im Umlauf zu halten, weil es wird ja nur weiter ähm nachgewiesen werden können,
ihn ausgeführt haben. Insofern sieht es gerade tatsächlich danach aus.
Dass dieses Unternehmen erledigt ist und dass vor allem auch die Verantwortlichen Strafen bekommen werden für das äh was sie getan haben.
Dass es nicht das Ende des Marktes für Staatstrojaner, ganz im Gegenteil, die haben wir jetzt ähm ich glaube zuletzt 18 Angestellte entlassen, zwischenzeitlich hatten sie mal 80 laut Wikipedia.
Aber diese Angestellten werden sich natürlich neue Jobs suchen und vermutlich bei der Konkurrenz.
Und die Konkurrenz wird auch die Kunden übernehmen, da werden ja jetzt nicht irgendwelche Staaten sitzen, die sagen oh Finn Fischer ist pleite, ähm das heißt wir haben jetzt keinen Staatstrojaner mehr, sondern die werden natürlich jetzt zu NSO gehen,
Insofern ist das ein Etappensieg, aber es sind wichtiger, der auch einfach mal zeigt so, okay aus deutschen.
Juriston könnt ihr eben nicht,
Schadsoftware machen und diese Schadsoftware an Bahraien, Bangladesch Brunai, Äthiopien, Ungarn, Malaysia, Mexiko, Katar und die Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate.
Verkaufen die die dann dagegen politische Oppositionelle einsetzen. Ja das ist ja schon dann mal so ein gewisser,
der da stattgefunden hat.
Zumindest mal ein ein klares Statement zumindest für wie wir das in Deutschland gerne so äh hätten
so, ne? Äh inwiefern das dann ein Vorbild und eine Vorlage für andere Länder äh ist, das steht auf einem ganz anderen Blatt, aber man muss es ja überhaupt selber erst mal richtig machen.
Genau und ähm das denke ich hat sich hier gezeigt,
Gut, wegen Verstoß äh gegen Exportkontrollen oder gegen also ohne Ausfuhrgenehmigung, aber immerhin. Und wer wie gesagt, wer weiß, vielleicht werden sie auch noch unschuldig gesprochen, bis
zur Verurteilung gilt er die Unschuldsvermutung, aber das, was hier eben unternommen wurde gegen dieses Unternehmen in in den juristischen Schritten, ihr seid schon nicht ohne.
Gleichzeitig muss man, glaube ich, an dieser Stelle mal sagen, wer diese Arbeit geleistet hat und das ist,
Dieses Unternehmen agiert ja seit weit über einem Jahrzehnt und so für den CCC auf die,
Agenda kam es ähm im Prinzip.
Nachdem mit Ozapft ist 20 11 ja so der erste deutsche Staatstrainer analysiert und zerfetzt worden war.
Und damit war ja klar, okay, die werden sich jetzt eine,
alternative Suchen und Gamma Finnfischer gab es damals schon, insofern war es auch naheliegend, dass sie in diese Richtung gehen würden und das haben sie ja dann auch getan.
Aber was ist eigentlich in den letzten zehn Jahren im Kampf gegen die Staatstrojaner passiert? Ähm wir haben erstens mal Betroffene und Zielpersonen, die die Angriffe auf sie entdeckt haben und die den Forscherinnen gemeldet haben,
Wir haben angestellte, Informantinnen und andere Whistleblower, die über diese Unternehmen berichtet haben, nicht zuletzt ja auch ähm.
Irgendwie, dass Andre jetzt von jemandem die Nachricht bekommt, okay, der Landesdicht. Herzlichen Glückwunsch, ihr Penner habt gewonnen.
Dann haben wir das die mehrere wichtige Finnfischer Analysen über die Jahre veröffentlicht haben.
Und ähm in letzter Zeit wahnsinnige Forschungen zu NSO-Pegasus machen, also dem israelischen Staatstrojaner, der ähm.
Also ungleich skandalöser noch ist. Äh wir haben Access Now, die die Analyse veröffentlicht haben,
über den Einsatz in der Türkei. Wir haben Leute wie Claudio Guineri, der der einzige ist, die an dieser Stelle nochmal namentlich erwähnen möchte, der seit vielen, vielen Jahren Staatsrehaner jagt,
auch irgendwie zu veröffentlichung zum Einsatz in Ägypten beteiligt ist und der,
Hauptentwickler oder der aktivste Entwickler zu Mobile Veryfication Tool Kit ist, mit dem sich ähm Infektionen auf Mobiltelefonen nachweisen lassen können. Also kannst du quasi bei iPhones schaust du die Backups durch,
dann sucht das Ding nach in die ähm.
Claudio arbeitet kann ich's dir nicht sagen, aber bestimmt seit zehn Jahren an diesem Kram,
er hat auch einen ähm Vortrag mal gehalten auf dem Congress, wo er auch mit der IT Security-Community ähm ein bisschen hart ins Gericht gegangen ist und gesagt hat, so weißt du,
fliegt hier von Unternehmen zu Unternehmen mit mit eurem IT Security Zirkus und fliegt Businessclass und so,
Und ähm wir sitzen hier mit ein paar wenigen Leuten und kämpfen gegen diese Staatstroja, ne? Beeindruckender Vortrag, den er da gehalten hat, weil es einfach mal ein Idealist ist.
Dann gibt's Phineas Fischer ähm ein Pseudonym der hat äh oder unter diesem Pseudonym würde, wenn ich mich nicht täusche, zwanzig vierzehn oder so,
Gamma ähm Finn Fischer gehackt und da gab's sehr viele Anhaltspunkte für die Attribution, also auch in unserem Report haben wir sehr viel ähm uns auf,
quasi auf dieses Lied bezogen, der war eben auch ein oder mehrere Samples drin.
Dann gibt's aber auch so ähm ja die klassischen Schadsoftwareforscher so.
Wichtige Analyse Microsoft hat äh Erkenntnisse zu Finn Fischer veröffentlicht,
dann eben kommen Gesellschaft für Freizeitrechte, Reporter ohne Grenzen,
und schreiben diese Strafanzeige, die jetzt, ne, auf den Schultern von äh Giganten,
dieses ähm Ergebnis ähm geliefert hat. Deswegen war das für uns sehr wichtig in der äh Pressemitteilung des CCC nochmal alle diese,
in die wenigen ähm Mitglieder dieser internationalen Community zu danken, die,
dafür sorgen, dass es für diese Branche schwer wird, sich gesellschaftlich und politisch äh akzeptiert zu werden. Und ja, diesen Kampf, der jetzt über,
ein Jahrzehnt von unterschiedlichen Akteuren mit wenig Geld und viel Herzblut ähm geführt wurde. Der hat jetzt hier sein.
Ergebnisse und da haben wir sicherlich noch ähm einiges vor uns. Insofern war uns das sehr wichtig, das noch mal hervorzuheben.
Meinen, dass die Organisation, die da jetzt an der Strafanzeige beteiligt waren, das alles nochmal erwähnen, aber äh für die haben wir's ja noch nicht gemacht.
Julian Assange. Schlechte Nachrichten.
Ja, habe ich jetzt äh kein Jingle dafür, weißt du, ne.
Schlechte Nachrichten ist der Jingle ganz am Anfang der Sendung.
Stimmt. Für richtig schlechte Nachrichten haben wir auch immer noch unser Mollintron. Aber soweit ist jetzt noch nicht.
So so schlimm ist es nicht. Äh ja Julian Assange hat ähm.
Ist jetzt auch schon wieder ein paar Wochen her. Wir haben ja längere Zeit keine Sendung gemacht. War jetzt vorm Supreme Court und äh um gegen seine.
Ähm also um Berufung einzulegen gegen das Urteil des High Cord im Dezember zwanzig einundzwanzig, das seiner Auslieferung an die USA zustimmte.
Also ursprünglich war es äh das Westminster Bezirksgericht, das
äh gesagt hatte, nee, der besteht unter äh der steht unter Suizidgefahr und ist äh nicht auslieferungsfähig. Dann hat der High Cord gesagt, nee, den könnt ihr ruhig mal in die USA geben.
Und dagegen hat er sich an Supreme Court gewehrt. So. Der Supremecode hat gesagt wir sind ja eigentlich kein Problem mit.
Und ähm damit geht der Fall jetzt zurück an das Westminster Bezirksgericht.
Wo ursprünglich wegen der gesundheitlichen, wegen des gesundheitlichen Zustandes Zustandes die Auslieferung abgelehnt wurde. So, aber dieses Bezirksgericht in Westminster.
Darf jetzt nur noch die Innenministerin auffordern, das zu entscheiden.
Ob Sie die Auslieferung entsprechend der gesetzlichen Grundlagen anordnen will oder nicht.
Pretty-Partell sagte ihr wahrscheinlich als Brite, mehr als mir, aber es ist jetzt, glaube ich, eher wenig Hoffnung, dass ausgerechnet Pretty Patel sagt, äh ähm.
Nee, den liefern wir nicht aus, oder?
Sehr unwahrscheinlich. Also die Frau ist nicht äh bekannt dafür, irgendwelche sinnvollen Entscheidungen zu fällen,
und äh gehört somit zu den schlimmsten in dieser ganzen äh Toreregierung, die da grade am Start ist. Ähm.
Ja, die ist ja auch maßgeblich,
dafür verantwortlich, dass irgendwie Großbritannien jetzt äh noch nicht mal geschafft hat, irgendwie eine nennenswerte Zahl an ukrainischen Flüchtlingen aufzunehmen und so weiter, weil,
Erstmal äh Paperwork zu ähm auszufüllen haben und Nachweise über.
Dokumente, die sie dann nicht haben und wochenlang erstmal einen Kalli festhängen, bevor sie überhaupt äh auch nur ansatzweise die Chance hatten. Also ich glaube vor einer,
einer Woche oder ist zwei Wochen her die Nachricht waren's irgendwie grad mal so fünfzig, die sie geschafft haben aufzunehmen und diese ist also,
ein Dauerausfall. Ich meine, die ganze Regierung ist ein ist ein Dauerausfall, aber sie ist sie ist so nehmen so ein paar anderen ähm Potentaten wie natürlich vor allem Boris Johnson,
Ist halt auch einfach so eine Regierung, die einfach, ne, ich meine, kannst dir ja vorstellen, wenn Boris Johnson,
schon so als äh Chefclown sich irgendwie äh da.
Der sein Kabinett besetzt.
Ja, also ich meine, das ist äh klar, dass die anderen auch alle nur so so Clowns und Ja-Sager sind. Also es ist wirklich the worst of the worst und von daher für ähm
Assange wäre es eigentlich mal ganz sinnvoll, dass es da zur Revolution kommt, aber ich glaube, es ist so ein bisschen wie mit dem Krieg in der Ukraine. Es wird erst noch ein bisschen schlimmer, bevor es besser wird und äh das ist so der Zustand, den auch gerade,
Großbritannien hat. Ist alles ganz schlimm, was da passiert.
Zwei Chancen hat Assange jetzt noch äh zwei Handlungsmöglichkeiten. Ähm einmal sagt seine Anwältin an äh also,
ähm nicht Stella Morris, die seine zukünftige Ehefrau, sondern äh seine äh
Chefanwältin quasi, äh dass er keine Berufung gegen alle wichtigen Aspekte, die vor dem Bezirksgericht in Westminster verhandelt wurden, eingelegt habe,
das könne er jetzt noch tun.
Also das nehme ich jetzt so zur Kenntnis wenn sie das sagt wird das so sein. Das heißt er kann eventuell nochmal ähm,
hier seine Auslieferung verzögern mit eventueller Aussicht darauf, sie sogar zu verhindern und wenn dann alle Rechtsmittel in Großbritannien ausgeschöpft sind, können sie immer noch zum,
EGMR nach Straßburg oder den den EGMR in Straßburg anrufen, also den ähm,
Europäischen Gerichtshof für Menschenrechte. Also zwei Handlungsmöglichkeiten gibt's hier noch, aber.
Sieht sieht jetzt nicht so gut aus die warum der Supremecourt jetzt echt da so 'ne Auslieferung zu.
Ist halt irgendwie auch schwer nachvollziehbar. Der Supremecode ist ja wenigstens mal so, das ist ja so eine Institution, wo man.
Üblicherweise sagen kann, okay, die entzieht sich dem des tagespolitischen Einflusses und da da kann man dann vielleicht auch mal sagen, okay
dann können die halt mal so 'ne Entscheidung treffen die wir unseren amerikanischen Freunden schwer vermitteln können aber wenn wir sagen ja gut dann war's eben so und dann tut uns das leid, dann muss der Assanches jetzt eben hier irgendwie in Großbritannien bleiben
ähm und vielleicht noch ein Jährchen absitzen, weil er oder oder ist ja, ihr müsst ja eigentlich sogar halt, ich glaube, die Strafe für ähm Entfernung aus diesem
aus diesem Graftum äh damals seid ihr ja schon längst abgesessen aber nein, äh aber nein. Dass das also nicht gut.
Und ähnlich nicht gut ist, dass äh Julian Hessenthaler verurteilt wurde.
Thomas, hatte das Jahr ähm hier erstens schon mal berichtet und dann die ähm Prozessbeobachtung auch gemacht.
Und der, der hat dreieinhalb Jahre Haft bekommen.
Wir wollen jetzt daran erinnern, dieses Verfahren, in dem er dreieinhalb Jahre Haft bekommen hat.
Wird ja betont, dass habe überhaupt nichts mit der Ibiza-Affäre zu tun, denn Julian Hessenthaler war derjenige, der maßgeblich dieses Video-Set-up,
quasi angelegt hat, die Legende dazu gestrickt hat,
dass äh der Strache sich da in Ibiza wiederfindet und ähm versucht mehr oder weniger,
russische Oligarchin davon zu überzeugen, dass er ihr mit Staatsaufträgen das refinanziert, mit überteuerten Staatsaufträgen das refinanziert, wenn sie die Krone kauft diese große
Boulevardzeitung in Österreich und damit politische Stimmung in seinem Interesse macht
ja? Das ist ein Vorschlag, den oder der hat auch sehr detailliert geschildert, wie so etwas funktioniert und in diesem Kontext sagt er ja auch, Lovomatik zahlt alle. Novomatik Glückspielkonzern, das sind auch immer äh,
Die wissen auch immer, wie man alles ganz korrekt macht, ja? Und ähm.
Die Situation. Thomas hatte das ja hier schon viel ausführlicher erklärt. Da gab's irgendwelche Belastungszeugen, die waren wegen Drogenhandels dran, hatten dann fünfstellige Kontoeingänge.
Dann ist ihnen auf einmal eingefallen, dass sie ein Kilo Koks von äh Julian Hessentaler gekauft haben. Aber erst nachdem ihnen 10.000 Euro auf dem Konto eingegangen sind,
und mit diesen Aussagen, die wo die Leute sich in eklatanten Aspekt.
Widersprechen, sowas wie wie oft habe ich den gesehen, wo habe ich den gesehen, wann war das eigentlich,
irgendwie in drei Aussagen, drei Varianten davon erzählen, wann der irgendwo Kilo Koks abgekauft oder verkauft hätte. Keinerlei Sachbeweise, nichts, kein Foto, kein gar nix. Sie haben einfach nur gesagt, ja der hat mir vor so vielen Jahren
Koks verkaufen, dann kriegt ihr so eine krasse Strafe dafür ähm das ist schon wirklich ähm,
Ja äh ich finde es erschütternd. Muss ich muss ich wirklich einfach sagen. Und Thomas hat das hier in der Sendung schon gesagt. Wenn nicht diese
Novomatik jetzt alles da dran getan hätte, diesen Typen irgendwie fertig zu machen und die Zeugen zu bezahlen.
Dann wär der selbstverständlich nicht verurteilt worden ja also dieser Einfluss auf die Justiz und das Verfahren ist wirklich irre,
Ich find's wirklich also fällt mir gar nichts mehr zu ein. Weiß nicht, wie du das siehst.
Mir fällt zu Österreich schon länger nichts mehr ein. Von daher bin ich jetzt nicht sonderlich äh überrascht, aber offensichtlich ähm ist jetzt der,
politische über die man sich ja durchaus hat früher freuen können noch nicht jetzt so tief in dieses System eingedrungen, dass es komplett,
nicht in der Lage äh Viren noch schlimme Dinge anzustellen. Also da sitzt der Filz dann doch schon ziemlich dick drin.
Und finde in solchen Sachen drückt sich das halt aus. Was da die Kräfte sind, kann ich ehrlich gesagt schwer genau benennen, aber,
erscheint mir das gerade nicht zu sein.
Irrsinn. Es ist einfach irre. Ja und man muss ja in dem Einzelfall immer sagen, okay, das kann sehr gut sein, dass äh.
Der äh diesen dass der vielleicht mal Kokain gehandelt hat. Es gibt ähm unterschiedliche
Reportagen, in denen er sagt, das ist nicht so gewesen und ich finde jetzt auch so ein Kilo ist halt auch echt eine ziemlich große Menge. Das kriegst du nicht so einfach und ähm.
Oder wird ja jetzt sagen wir hier im Görlitzer Park in Berlin nicht als handelsüblich angeboten, ja? Äh in in der Menge ähm die.
Also
er selber leugnet das natürlich und im Einzelfall muss man immer sagen, ja es kann kann ja trotzdem gut sein, wer weiß und dann hat man vertraut man auf das Verfahren. Aber wenn das Verfahren jetzt auf einmal mit irgendwelchen drogenabhängigen Belastungszeugen
stattfindet, die irgendwie ähm Kohleeingänge haben von der Novomatik,
oder von dem Nowomatik-Eigner, das ist halt schon ein bisschen komisch, ja. Und wie gesagt.
Im der Einzelfall, in dem vertraue ich dann vielleicht auf die Justiz. Aber irgendwie häufen sich diese Einzelfälle bei Whistleblowern. Ja, wir schauen uns irgendwie Julian Assange an. Ähm in keinem dieser Fälle,
kann kann ich die Aussage treffen, weil es mir einfach nicht zusteht das zu beurteilen ob die zugrunde.
Gelegt oder zur Last gelegte Straftat,
begangen wurde oder nicht. Das weiß ich einfach nicht. Ja, was ich aber sehe, ist, dass für einen für diese Straftat sehr sehr ungewöhnlicher Aufwand getrieben wird.
Um die Menschen zu verurteilen, ja.
Drogenhändler. Meine Güte, über Jahre verfolgt mit ein paar äh mit mit bestochenen Zeugen für einen einmaligen Fall.
Julian Assange ähm diesen ganzen diese ganzen Unregelmäßigkeiten hat ja der Nils Melzer.
Aufgearbeitet, der dann eben sagt, okay, ja, natürlich gibt es hier den Verdacht einer Straftat und die ist auch nennenswert, aber
dass man über Jahre die Vernehmungen verhindert und
quasi diesen Menschen in in diese fürchterliche Situation bringt, dass er sich eben jahrelang da versteckt, während er eigentlich sagt, ich mache doch eine Aussage, lass mich das bitte aus der Ferne machen. Ich,
bin besorgt, dass ihr mich in dem Moment, wo ich bei euch bin, nicht mehr gehen lasse und mich an die USA ausliefert. Ähm,
sind schon sehr auffällige Muster, die man dann immer bei den Whistleblowern sieht. Wie gesagt, die einzelne potentielle Straftat von Julian Assange oder so will ich jetzt nicht äh beurteilen, da kann ich gar nicht beurteilen,
aber ähm viele Leute haben jahrelang gesagt, wartet mal ab, irgendwann holen die Amerikaner ihre ähm.
Ihr aus der Tasche und jahrelang musste Julian Assange sich anhören, das ist äh Quatsch, was du erzählst, aber in dem Moment, wo es den Regierungswechsel in Ecuador gab.
Fliegt da raus. Das hat ja Minuten gedauert,
bis sie den da rausgezerrt haben und die Amis irgendwie weiß ich nicht wie viel wie viele Seiten von diesem rausgeholt haben und gesagt haben so ach jetzt hätten wir den übrigens gerne,
Wo ihr den grade mal aus der Botschaft äh rausgezerrt habt
So und das war jahrelang galt das als Verschwörungstheorie, ja. Oder als als Ablenkungsmanöver von Julian Assange, der sich der der den ähm Vorwürfen wegen Vergewaltigung entgehen möchte.
Das sind ja die gezielten und intendierten Ergebnisse solcher Verfahren,
Die Leute sich denken, ey, weißt du was? Das das signalisiert doch einfach nur, leg dich mit den Mächtigen an und die finden etwas,
Finden etwas und es ist völlig egal, was es ist und du wirst dafür dein Leben ruiniert bekommen. Dreieinhalb Jahre ist ja fast noch ein relativ wenig, ja, also es ist es ruiniert,
vielleicht jetzt noch ein also ne, das ist möglich, aber das ist auf auf jede andere Person, die sich das anschaut.
Natürlich eine ganz äh eine ganz finstere Aussicht,
es ist auch noch nicht gesagt, dass sie den Hessentaler jetzt in Ruhe lassen. Jetzt haben sie nicht erst mal dreieinhalb Jahre Zeit, die der Schmort ähm gibt natürlich noch Berufung, würde ich jetzt mal von ausgehen und so weiter, aber den werden sie sein Leben lang nicht mehr in Ruhe lassen,
Das ist nicht so, dass die sagen werden, äh okay, wenn er die dreieinhalb Jahre abgesessen hat, ist gut, sondern die werden denen einfach das gesamte Leben verfolgen und fertig machen,
Und diese Aussicht, äh das macht es nicht einfach nur aus Rachsüchtigkeit, sondern auch einfach also als Rachsucht, sondern auch einfach, um allen anderen zu zeigen, Leute, überlegt es euch gut.
Das finde ich ähm schockierend und deswegen sind äh sämtliche ähm juristischen Bemühungen, zivilgesellschaftlichen Bemühungen, legislativen Bemühungen zum whistleblower Schutz,
einerseits so wichtig und andererseits erstaunlicherweise immer irgendwie von Misserfolg gekrönt. Habe ich den Eindruck.
Ja also man würde ja meinen, dass wir sehen das ja zum Beispiel auch in Deutschland so mit äh.
Beschlussumsetzung gegen Korruption und so da da tun sich dann die Parlamente auf einmal dann doch ähm sehr schwer solche Sachen durchzuführen und auch diese ganzen.
Sachen, die eigentlich in der Bevölkerung, glaube ich, eine große Unterstützung haben, ne. Tun sich dann äh so auf den letzten Metern auch schwer, dass man einfach diese ganzen Regelungen irgendwie problematisch sieht, weil natürlich dann auch alle im Apparat Schiss haben.
Zu Recht oder nicht zurecht, ja? So oh. Wenn wir das jetzt so äh ermöglichen, dass ja jeder die Klappe aufmachen kann, dann sieht ja jeder, wie schmutzig unser Klo ist.
Ja und äh genau so funktionieren diese Machtregime und deswegen muss man auch so gegen die kämpfen. Und äh ihnen entgegentreten.
Na ja und dann notfalls kannst du ja halt nach Russland fliehen.
Mir ist aber echt nicht witzig. Mit dem Loch eine eine krasse Nachricht.
Krass es jetzt gut oder schlecht?
Alles ist krass. Unsere Sendung, wir haben krossesten Podcast. Das müsst ihr inzwischen den Hörerinnen aufgefallen sein.
Am krassesten oder am krossesten.
Beides natürlich. Also dieses ähm ja wie nennt man das? Also eigentlich.
Handys, die sich äh so äh die öffentlich vorgetragenen Ergebnisse einer äh
sehr, sehr besonderen Beliebtheit unter
kriminellen erfreut haben. Das waren so Handys, die wenn man sie auf wenn man beim guten Knopf gedrückt hat, sind sie
eine spezielle Umgebung gebootet, sonst in eine andere und in dieser speziellen Umgebung wurden dann verschlüsselter Messenger und verschlüsselte Telefonie ähm
Angeboten von einem,
von eben einem Anbieter mit Namen oder was, ja? Also die haben letztendlich besonders gesicherte Endgeräte mit einer Service äh Subscription,
verkauft und ähm.
Das ist das ist das, was dieses Unternehmen getan hat. Ja ähm nachher kommt raus, dieses Produkt,
hat sich in der organisierten Kriminalität offenbar einer A,
besonderen ähm besonderen Beliebtheit erfreut und andererseits auch einem besonders hohen Vertrauen, weil als es dann dieses Unternehmen wurde dann eben gehackt.
Von, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe von französischen Behörden,
dieses komplette Unternehmen gehackt haben und dann manipulierte,
Firmware-Updates verteilt haben, die am Ende dazu geführt haben, dass diese Kommunikation, die die Kundinnen des Unternehmens für verschlüsselt hielten, vollständig ausgeliefert wurde.
An deren Server. Und das haben Sie relativ lange so laufen lassen, bis Sie sehr, sehr, sehr viele Daten ähm.
Gesammelt haben von sehr, sehr vielen Nutzern dieses Systems. Und dann sind sie zu dem Ergebnis gekommen zu sagen so erstens.
Das sind alles Kriminelle, das können wir an den Inhalten sehen und weil wir die ja jetzt hier abgehört haben, äh werden wir die jetzt äh anhand dieser Beweise, die sich in den Nachrichten ähm.
Finden,
werden wir die jetzt alle nach und nach der Strafverfolgung zuführen. Und ähm soweit quasi die französische Linie. Jetzt äh gab es dann einen Fall in Deutschland, wo sie äh quasi, wo die deutschen Behörden.
Jetzt einen Angeklagten in Deutschland,
mit den Beweismitteln aus diesem verurteilen wollen. Er hat natürlich, ist ja klar, die äh Anwältin oder der Anwalt der der oder des Beschuldigten.
Gesagt, alles klar. Ich gehe nicht davon aus, dass diese angebrachten Beweismittel.
Überhaupt vor einem deutschen Gericht verwendbar sind, weil hier hat ja immerhin jemand eine Kommunikationsinfrastruktur gehackt und äh das darf man doch gar nicht.
Bundesgericht zu Folgendes. Erstens die Franzosen haben irgendwann mal festgestellt, dass sie diese Telefone bei Drogenhändlern finden.
Dann haben die Franzosen, die also die französischen Strafverfolgungsbehörden ein Ermittlungsverfahren unter anderem wegen des Verdachts der Bildung einer kriminellen Vereinigung eingeleitet.
Haben festgestellt, dass die verschlüsselte Kommunikation zwischen den Nutzern über einen französischen Server läuft.
Dann haben Sie auf die Daten des Servers zugegriffen und haben festgestellt, dass es irgendwie so und so viel Zehntausende äh SIM-Karten gibt, die das irgendwie nutzen und die in vielen europäischen Ländern verwendet wurden.
Dann haben sie die Daten entschlüsseln können. Da wird nicht weiter drauf eingegangen, wie das gemacht wurde und haben festgestellt, äh dass es da eben sehr viele Hinweise auf illegale Aktivitäten gibt,
dann hat Frankreich diese Erfassung einer Abfangen einer Abfangeinrichtung auf diesem Server,
genehmigt am 1ten April 2020. Also in Frankreich ist das legal gewesen. Franzosen sagen,
Jedenfalls 7363 Prozent der Telefone,
kriminelle Zwecke, die übrigen Geräte entweder inaktiv oder noch nicht ausgewertet. Also,
könnte hat halt 'ne sehr spezifische Nutzerbasis gehabt, was aber ehrlich gesagt nicht notwendigerweise Schuld der Anbieterin ist
wenn Sie halt ein sicheres Systemboard. Problem ist, dass es offenbar nicht sicher war und jetzt hat das äh BKA gesagt, okay.
Wir möchten diese Beweise verwenden. Und jetzt sagt der BGH ja also die verfassungsgemäße Rechtsgrundlage für die Verwertung.
Ist die SDPO und das gilt auch für die im Wege der Rechtshilfe erlangten Daten. Und.
Es gibt keine ausdrückliche Regelung.
Dass solche Beweise nur eingeschränkt verwendet dürfen. Mit anderen Worten, hier ist jetzt vielleicht eine Verletzung des Fernmeldegeheimnisses nach deutschem Recht erfolgt, aber in Frankreich war's legal.
Und wir haben ähnliche Mittel, zum Beispiel online Durchsuchung, äh akustische Home Wohnraumüberwachung und so weiter. Also.
Diese gesamte Maßnahme, die da stattgefunden hat ähm.
Sehen wir nicht, dass hier ein äh Beweisverwertungsverbot besteht und zwar unter keinem rechtlichen Gesichtspunkt. Mit anderen Worten,
Französische Behörden gehen hin, hacken einen Kommunikationsinfrastruktur, nehmen Full Take alle Daten raus,
Weil sie sagen, das wird ja nur von Kriminellen verwendet, lesen das alles, werten am Ende ein paar Verfahren daraus aus oder ein paar mehr,
die Beweise nach Deutschland und Deutschland darf sie verwenden.
Das ist schon relativ also in seiner Konsequenz ein relativ krasses Urteil, weil das eben ähm.
Na ja, das Hecken von Kommunikationsinfrastruktur letztendlich zu einem sinnvollen zu einer sinnvollen Strategie,
Strafverfolgungsbehörden macht und es ist eine Sache zu sagen, okay ihr könnt einen Staatstrojaner haben von Finnfischer oder von NSO Group
und könnt den auf die Endgeräte der Nutzerinnen irgendwie aufbringen und könnt so irgendwie ihre die Geräte einzelner Personen hacken. Das ist eine ganz andere Sache.
Wenn man halt die Nutzerbasis eines kompletten Unternehmens,
einer kompletten ähm Kommunikationsinfrastruktur. Also das ist schon echt eine ziemlich äh üble Geschichte.
Ja, ist wieder so ein juristisches Outsourcing, ne, wo wir so dieses.
Sehen, dass die ganzen äh unterschiedlichen Umsetzungen europäischer Richtlinien ähm,
So so ist denn überhaupt jetzt von europäischen Richtlinien betroffen ist oder die generelle Gestaltung
des des Rechtsrahmens in die einzelnen europäischen Ländern dann immer ganz gut verwendet werden kann mit so na ja also wir hätten das ja jetzt nicht gedurft aber bei denen war das ja erlaubt und.
Ne? Am Ende sind wir ja dann doch irgendwie alle alles einen Rechtsraum, dann passt das schon. Schwierig.
Das ist das ist ja eigentlich dieses äh Jurestiction Londaring, was wir von Geheimdiensten eben auch kennen, ne, also was bei dem einen darfst, darfst du bei dem anderen nicht, hier Inlandsgeheimdienst, Auslandsgeheimnisrechte, die Tasche, linke Tasche ähm.
Also wenn man jetzt also das ist ein ein Infrastruktur sorry eines eines Kommunikationsanbieters. So als nächstes hacken sie Facebook oder was?
Wir lesen uns mal Facebook durch. Oh Mann ey. Das muss man sich mal vorstellen, was das bedeuten würde. Ich meine, das ist natürlich jetzt für die so eine kleine Nummer. Im Vergleich, ne, zu Facebook oder.
Zehntausende Nutzer, ähm das Übel, also das Üble ist ja, dass solche also solche Eklatanten,
Befugnisausweitungen natürlich üblicherweise in diesen Kontexten stattfinden,
So ja hier kriminelle Vereinigung Drogenhandel.
Nicht alles, ne? Da kommt das dann immer und dann wird gesagt, ja das ist in Ordnung. Das da kann man auch mal ein Auge zudrücken und wenn's bei schwerster Kriminalität und wir kennen es ja mit dem Staatstrojaner
Ja und es ist ja auch nicht so, als wäre jetzt die erste äh Kommunikationsinfrastruktur, die irgendwie gehackt wird. Ähm.
Erinnere sich an Belga Komm, ja? Aber der Unterschied zwischen Geheimdiensten und Polizei,
ja wenigstens immer der gewesen, dass du sagst, okay der Geheimdienst kann da zwar überall rein, ja? Der der hat die Befugnis, aber der hat nicht,
der kann dich nicht nachher dafür vor Gericht bringen und der da wo du vorm Gericht landest gibt's eben den Richtervorbehalt und da kannst du vielleicht darauf hoffen, dass den dass der Polizei nicht das Recht gegeben wird, deinen kompletten Kommunikationsanbieter zu hängen,
und dich auf diese Weise, muss man jetzt mal dazu sagen, auf diese Weise jetzt hier Beweise.
Gegen diese Menschen erbracht werden. Das Bittere ist natürlich.
Es sind offenbar Beweise, die Verfahren laufen ja relativ gut und ähm ich würde jetzt auch vermuten, dass wenn du irgendwie halt dir so einen geholt hast, dass du halt auch nicht irgendwie so ein Eckendealer warst, sondern jemand, der in größeren.
Voluminar äh im im Hole Sale als als Großist äh unterwegs war, ja? Und dann haste natürlich auch schnell mal äh ziemlich unangenehme ähm Strafverfahren an der Backe und,
gibt denen natürlich jetzt Rückenwind, wenn sie diese Daten auswerten. Nichtsdestotrotz äh finden sie die überhaupt den die den den Anhaltspunkt.
Bestimmte Personen des Drogenhandels zu bezichtigen oder zu überführen oder zu,
sogar zu verurteilen. In überhaupt erst dadurch, dass sie einen Kommunikationsanbieter gehackt haben, also eine etwas in meinen Augen rechtswidriges überhaupt begangen haben.
Mir gefällt nicht der äh und das ist auch so ein Begriff, den man den man nur den man sich muss. Ähm.
Es ist eine ein Dammbruch, weil du jetzt schon mal quasi so ein BGH-Urteil hast,
der nächste wird sich darauf beziehen und dann muss es nicht mehr nur zu
60 oder mehr Prozent kriminell genutzt worden sein, seine Reihen vielleicht auch mal fuffzig oder auch mal 25 und dann wird gesagt, ja der Staat, der ist ja in Ordnung, der guckt hier nur mal rein, der äh verurteilt ja jetzt auch nur die Kriminellen, dann ist es vielleicht gar nicht so schlimm, dass er in seinem Heck
99Prozent unbescholtene Bürger hat und jetzt einfach mal durchwurstet. Das so läuft der Hase doch.
Ja, ja beziehungsweise man muss natürlich dann äh letzten Endes auf eine europäische ähm.
Richtlinie oder noch besser ähm Verordnung drängen, wo man's halt auch mal klar regelt, wie wie nun eigentlich der Hase äh läuft, ist ja alles ein Prozess.
Tim, ich glaube, das das was jetzt kommt ist, ich äh ist nicht unbedingt eine gute Nachricht, aber ich glaube, du betrachtest es als äh Silberstreif.
Findest du?
Weiß ich nicht, du bist ja schon du bist ja äh völlig verblendeter Blockchain-Hasser.
Ich ja mal so sagen. Du hast ja überhaupt gar keine Ahnung. Der also der Wind ist wandels weht. Der der Wind des Wandels weht und äh du sperrst dich dagegen.
Indem du sagst das werden Ponys geben. Alles ist ein Pony, es gehen du hast sogar keine Ahnung von Wirtschaft. So.
Oder? Also ich wollte jetzt mal kurz die die Argumentation zusammenfassen.
Es geht um Kryptogeld, ne? Genau. Ja, geht immer nur dadrum, klar.
Ja, na ja gut, also ich meine ich finde ja äh das Thema hat unsere unsere Beobachtung und Kommentierung verdient.
Ja und das ist auch äh wird noch ein Dauerthema bleiben für eine ganze ganze Weile.
Aber ähm Dinge bewegen sich so und es gab ja jetzt auch grade,
letzten Wochen wieder viel Bohai um
äh Währung auf äh ja auf jeder äh Ebene, also täglich, um das mal auch noch mal klarzumachen so,
täglich hast du Nachrichten über,
Hier mal 200 Millionen US-Dollar verloren. Da mal irgendwie einen Scam mit 50 Millionen. Hier nochmal 6hundert Millionen, die irgendwie äh äh irgendwo gestohlen wurden, wo Leute aus irgendwelchen Deals rausgegangen sind, wo es Hacks gab von irgendwelchen Exchanges und so.
Würden wir würden wir das alles hier aufzählen, dann dann hätten wir überhaupt gar nix anderes mehr zu berichten,
das ist einfach da so das kann man sich irgendwie schön auf äh Webs going great,
den Blog äh durchlesen, da da tickert das einfach so die ganze Zeit durch. Also das ist so so ein so ein permanenter Film. Die eigentliche Frage ist ja eben wie blicken wir da netzpolitisch drauf und ich glaube, dass da auch äh viel,
Spaltungspotenzial ist. Also man hat schon auch Leute, die sagen wir mal so einen bestimmten Freiheitsbegriff pflegen.
Im Netz auch vor allem, ja, die äh sehr wohl äh diese vorherrschende Meinung oder vielleicht ja auch nicht vorherrschende existierende Meinungen, dass dass sich mit diesen Kryptogeldern eine gewisse.
Freiheit, implementieren lässt oder sie eine solche äh repräsentiert, die da äh durchaus mitgehen, ne und es gibt irgendwie eine einen kritischeren Teil, der erstmal ganz andere Probleme sieht. Wir haben ja hier schon darüber gesprochen.
Ausführlich und vor allem ähm jetzt auch
aus der Reguliererposition heraus, also aus der und in dem Fall, wo wir jetzt drüber sprechen werden, aus der europäischen Perspektive heraus, eben auch so das Problem sieht, dass ähm,
Man sich durch diese neuen Transferwege äh für Geld,
Probleme eintritt, was halt so die Klassiker betrifft, Geldwäsche, Terrorismus, äh Finanzierung ne oder auch,
Staatsterrorismusfinanzierung, da geht's natürlich jetzt hier vor allem auch um äh Geldrettung aus Russland äh et cetera.
Aber und das wird dann wieder auf der anderen Seite auch vorgeführt, so jetzt ja aber Ukraine nimmt ja auch Spenden über Kryptogeld an und so weiter. Also es ist so eine so eine offene, wild geführte Debatte. Nichtsdestotrotz hat sich ähm jetzt auch das EU-Parlament.
Mit dem äh Thema auseinandersetzen müssen, denn die EU-Kommission hat ja einen entsprechenden Gesetzesvorschlag,
eingereicht und wir wissen ja in der EU läuft das immer so, hm die Initiative geht immer von der Kommission aus,
Das Parlament ist ja nicht initiativberechtigt, sondern das Parlament verhält sich zu den Vorschlägen, die aus der Kommission kommen.
Und ja, die äh EU-Kommission, die hat einfach hier,
Bedarf gesehen und hat einen Vorschlag gemacht, der halt so darauf zielt so, wie sie das so schön nennen, anonyme Krypto-Walletts zu untersagen,
und vor allem eben Transfer von Kryptovermögenswerten in irgendeiner Form nachvollziehen zu können.
Also hier geht's quasi auch um eine Deanonymisierung dieser Zahlungswege, weil das ist ja das, was wir auch in dem normalen Finanzsystem sehen und dass es quasi Ausdruck des Wunsches, dass das eben hier auch nicht anders zu laufen hat
tatsächlich war dann aber auch eine Bagatellgrenze vorgesehen von tausend Euro.
Also nach dem Motto, wenn eine Zahlung nicht höher als 1tausend Euro liegt, was dann natürlich immer eine Frage ist, okay.
Wert hat den Bitcoin denn jetzt sozusagen, also wer definiert denn jetzt gerade äh überhaupt den den Wechselkurs, ja? Wer wer ist denn hier irgendwie offiziell? Das war sozusagen die Vorlage und jetzt muss ich ja das Parlament dazu verhalten und es sind tatsächlich zwei,
Ausschüsse des EU-Parlaments, die das diskutiert haben. Ist auf der einen Seite der Ausschuss für Wirtschaft und Währung, den kannte ich noch gar nicht. Econ.
Und die mir schon öfter gehabt haben, Justiz und Inneres, der liebe,
Ausschuss des EU-Parlaments und ähm ja, da gibt's ja dann immer so Berichterstatter, in dem Fall ist das irgendwie so einer ausm rechten Spektrum und ein Grüner. Und äh ja, nach den Verhandlungen in diesen Ausschüssen, spricht sich das EU-Parlament.
Mehrheitlich für eine Deanonymisierung von Kryptogeldzahlungen aus.
Und kassiert dabei aber auch gleich noch diese Bagatellgrenze. Also hat im Prinzip.
Ich das jetzt so mal richtig interpretiere, den Vorschlag der der Kommission sogar noch verschärft an der Stelle.
Ist ja immer wichtig, wie sich diese Ausschüsse verhalten, weil das was eben diese Ausschüsse beschließen, das ist dann halt,
in der Regel auch die Meinung und Haltung des Parlaments, sprich wenn es im Parlament dann zu einer Abstimmung darüber kommt,
dann kann man in der Regel davon ausgehen, dass das Parlament dementsprechend, weil dann eben die Fraktion sich äh entsprechend verhalten äh dass es dann auch dazu kommt,
Das ist dann quasi das Statement, die Erwiderung des EU-Parlaments, das geht dann eben äh letzten Endes wieder zum,
Kommission und zum Rat und am Ende gibt's diesen Trilog wo verhandelt wird und dann äh einigt man sich und dann wird das auch.
Parlament abgesegnet in der Form, wenn man dann eben sich auf einen Kompromiss geeinigt hat. Also das ist jetzt hier alles noch im Prozess und wir erwähnen das halt einfach, um einfach mal drauf hinzuweisen,
Derzeit auch überhaupt diskutiert wird. Es gab dann so zwischenzeitlich sogar die Überlegung generell Proof of Work zu verbieten. Das hat sich aber nicht durchgesetzt
Und generell scheint mir diese ganze Debatte so ein bisschen auch äh immer wieder von dieser Diskussion getragen zu sein, dass man ja hier äh,
Potentiell innovationsverhindernd.
Ähm wirkt. Ne, ist ja klar. Man hat ja irgendwie so eine neue Technologie. Die Technologie behauptet so, oh ich bin ganz toll und ich kann ganz viel,
Blühende Landschaften produzieren.
Dann gibt's halt Leute, die finden das eben genauso und dann gibt's halt Leute, die sagen so, ja, nee, blinden Landschaften ist bei euch äh Quatsch so, ihr seid einfach mehr ein Problem.
Da bewegt sich das so hin und her.
Ja, was ist dabei rausgekommen? Also letztlich würde das bedeuten, dass die europäische Bankenaufsichtsbehörde, BA
ein öffentliches Register von Unternehmen und Diensten erstellt, die in irgendeiner Form mit diesen Krypto-Assets zu tun haben und bei denen hohes Risiko für Geldwäsche, äh Terrorismusfinanzierung und andere kriminelle Aktivitäten besteht,
Freue mich, welche, welche das wohl sein könnten dann so in Anbetracht der Tatsache, dass.
Eigentlich im Wesentlichen so die wirtschaftliche Aktivität in diesem Bereich ist. Mhm außer von überteuerten Bürgern natürlich.
Andere Kriminelle.
Andere Krümel. Ja so was halt sonst noch so äh ist, ne? Genau und die Abgeordneten sind halt der Meinung, sie bräuchten halt irgendwie am Ende eine Liste von Anbietern, die diesen Vorschriften halt äh
nicht entsprechen. So um dann halt entsprechender vorzugehen. Ja gut, gab dann äh zum Beispiel eine Reaktion vom Bitcom
Mal ganz interessant, wie die sich so positionieren und ich glaube, die sind einfach äh noch voll so auf ihrer Blockchain-Illusion äh unterwegs so.
Sind ja so generell der Meinung, man müsse ja den Vertrauen in den Kryptomarkt stärken und sowas, ne? Ähm.
Und meinen, irgendwie ja, dass zukunftsträchtige Kryptogeschäft sei ja nach wie vor würde ja nach wie vor nicht verstanden werden.
Ihr habt ja richtig, stimmt. Habt ihr habt da hat wenigstens ihr seid so nah dran, ihr seid so nah dran.
So nah dran.
Ja, ne,
Zusammenhang meinen sie aber auch und das ist ja auch nicht ganz falsch, ne, dass es ja auch äh so was wie Chain Analyse-Tools gibt et cetera. Also diese ganze Debatte mit wie anonym ist denn das Ganze,
Ähm die kann man ja führen, ne? Also das ist Falle von Bitcoin ist der Varietäten mit jetzt verschiedenen Währungen, aber wir konzentrieren uns mal jetzt im Wesentlichen dadrauf, wie auch irgendwie oder so was und das ähm,
Ähm aber ich muss Ethereum sagen, damit ich irgendwie äh mit den coolen Kids mithalten kann, habe ich gehört, ne?
Man sollte schon wissen, wie man ein Wort ausspricht.
Ich kann auch iserieren sagen, das klingt so ein bisschen alberner dann halt.
Steht's im Duden? Nee, siehste.
Nee, eben nicht. Dann würde es wahrscheinlich Ethereum heißen. Oder oder bei dir bei dir würde es Etherieum heißen?
Ja ist doch auch schön. Ethereum. Einigen waren's auf Ethereum.
Wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall diese äh Blockchain ist ja quasi ein ein ewiges Lockfall aller Transaktionen und mittlerweile gibt's halt so zehn Analyse-Tools, das sind halt einfach Programme,
sich diese ganze äh Blockchain, die jetzt irgendwie hunderte von Gigabytes groß ist und betrachten das einfach als das, was es nämlich ist, nämlich eine Datenbank, mehr ist es ja nicht,
Database und diese Glorify Database ja,
da da kann man dann sozusagen, wenn irgendwo ein bekannter Geldfluss war, so hier wurde Geld von Person X umgetauscht
Kann man halt sehen, in welche äh Bitcoin-Transaktion oder Transaktion, dass ähm.
Übergegangen ist und selbst wenn es dann auf tausend aufgespalten und wieder zusammengeführt wird ja äh kann man da eben,
Darüber ein Tracing machen. Man kann's natürlich alles sehr verbessern und schwierig machen ähm nur,
Der Ansatz der EU-Kommission ist halt ein anderer. Der ist halt einfach so, ja nee, äh braucht man gar nicht erst mit an. Wenn ihr daran teilnehmen wollt, dann seid ihr einfach verpflichtet, hier irgendwo auch,
Kontaktdaten anzugeben und das soll dann halt im Wesentlichen für alle Player in diesem System gelten, die in irgendeiner Form intermediär wirken. So, das heißt, wenn ich,
dir jetzt Bitcoin von meiner privaten Wallet überweise, ja, dann gilt das nicht.
Ja, sondern der Tausch in echtes Geld. Also da.
Nicht nur der tauscht ein echtes Geld, sondern auch über Plattformen. Also selbst wenn ich dir über eine andere Plattform mit einer Wolle, die ich auf irgendeiner Bitcoin äh Plattform habe, darüber was schicke, dann würde das schon gelten. Aber nicht, wenn ich,
direkt ohne die Hilfe dieser Plattform mache.
Ah, das heißt, sie wollen die Kriminellen jetzt darüber trocken legen, dass die irgendwann alle die Kies zu ihren Rollets verschludert haben und äh Festplatten aufm Schrott suchen?
Wo soll das hinführen.
Ja, na ja gut. Also kannst du dir vorstellen, die Kryptobörsen sind auf jeden Fall alle äh richtig heiß irgendwie hier Coinbase
tobt wohl und hat auch interessanterweise ein Massenmal-Tool, womit man seinen Protest an die äh Parlamente schicken kann, an die Parlamentarier schicken kann eingerichtet,
Hatten wir das nicht schon mal von den besten lernen, sage ich nur.
Ich glaube ehrlich gesagt, die die sind sich einfach nur auf ihre Herkunft als als Spammer oder? Würde ich würde denen eine Spämervergangenheit zutrauen?
Was weiß ich. Auf jeden Fall die Argumentation ist natürlich dann halt auch wieder äh Rude, ne, so nach dem Motto ja hier Spenden für die Ukraine, das ist doch auch was Tolles und das würde ja dann alles verhindert werden, was natürlich Quatsch ist, weil ich kann ja auch heute schon.
Für die Ukraine zu tun? Ach so, man soll an die Ukraine ach so.
Weil auch die Ukraine Bitcoin aufgemacht hat.
Spenden können. Ja sicher Tim und auch eben um Gas zu bezahlen brauchen wir das auch und NFTs.
Ja, genau. Na ja, egal, wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall das EU-Parlament verhält sich. Es gibt da einen Prozess. Wir werden das ähm beobachten.
Es gibt ja noch diese also wenn ich wenn ich da den Bitcoin höre der äh der Bitcom,
der feststellt, dass diese Technologie noch nicht verstanden wurde, ne? Also oh man, also das das ist ja tatsächlich so, dass die Leute das nicht verstanden haben, ne und das ist äh,
mir tun die auch auf eine Weise leid jetzt diese ganzen.
FDPler oder so, die da rumrennen und sich sagen, also muss ja auch mal wenigstens eine eine Minute sich in die reinfüllen, dass die halt so sehen, so ey, wir haben,
ganzen Innovationen, wo es das schöne Geld gab, ne, da haben wir immer als Deutschland doof dagestanden, ne und jetzt,
Jetzt kommt hier aber Blockchain und diesen Zug den nehmen wir jetzt. Wir haben die anderen alle fahren lassen.
Ja? Aber den nehmen wir und man kann ja auch verstehen, dass die in voller Begeisterung jetzt auf diesen Zug aufspringen und sagen bloß nicht schon wieder den Zug verpassen.
Aber wenn du halt dir dann wenn du einfach nur so am Bahnhof stehst und den Zug siehst und denkst so nein den,
den nicht, der fährt in die falsche Richtung, ja? Das ist halt dann äh dramatisch, dramatisch.
Ich glaube ein paar Themen, die wir ähm ich sage mal überspringen. Es wird gerade viel.
Über den.
Der Influenza gesprochen und das ist ja auch von kulturellem Interesse durchaus spannend. Ich da auch einige Leute aus der Ukraine, denen ich dann folge, die dann da jetzt ja.
Versuchen.
Inhalte zu vermitteln und Situationen zu vermitteln und dann der Kampf diese Informationen zu den Russinnen und Russen zu bringen.
Wo ein stärkeres Zensurregime herrscht ähm alles so ein bisschen Aspekte, die wir vielleicht mal ausm weiter außen vor lassen, aber es gibt natürlich dann,
die wirklichen Heldinnen sind jetzt nicht irgendwelche Instagram-Stripper, sondern Leute wie Marina Ofsianikowa, die halt einfach mal ins Fernsehen geht,
Ins russische Fernsehen und ähm.
Russland und da wirklich sich in eine äh Gefahr begibt, der äh Strafverfolgung und äh so weiter.
Also man muss bei ihr natürlich sagen, sie hat sich da nicht hinbegeben. Sie war da schon, weil sie Teil dieses Systems war für viele Jahre, ne.
Genau, sie hat ja äh jahrelang äh gearbeitet bei diesem TV-Sender und dann eben ihre äh Gelegenheit genutzt, als es jetzt eben in den Krieg ging. Ähm.
Das sind so die Sachen, die ich dann irgendwie spannender finde als äh irgendwie was was
pasten Leute auf ähm Instagram. Aber man sieht immerhin, dass es seine Wirkung zeigt, weil Russland ja schon versucht, gegen Facebook und Instagram irgendwie vorzugehen, um da mehr Zensur reinzubringen,
Jetzt gibt's natürlich dann den Effekt, dass in Europa, wenn ich mich nicht täusche, hier äh Sputnik und Russia Today,
auch quasi als Fake-News-Sender ähm.
Am Senden gehindert werden sollen. Theoretisch keine nicht mehr das Recht zur Verbreitung ihres Rundfunks haben. Und das ist natürlich ein ein Thema, was sehr, sehr schwierig zu diskutieren ist.
Weil man natürlich aus seiner westlichen Wohlstands verwahrlosten,
ethischen Kompasssituation dann sagt, ja dann seid ihr nicht besser als Putin, doch. Putin führt einen Angriffskrieg, ja, da gibt's schon nochmal einen Unterschied,
Gleichzeitig fühl ich persönlich mich trotzdem nicht wohl damit dass,
jetzt aus dem europäischen Wertekanon eben auch derartige Informations ähm Einschränkungen stattfinden und das, was man eben, ja, im weitesten Sinne als Zensur.
Bezeichnen muss. Ähm auf der anderen Seite schwingt er natürlich mit.
Ich meine, was haben wir für Idioten in Deutschland? Und wenn wir jetzt also wirklich, was haben wir für Idioten in diesem Land? Und,
Wenn die jetzt alle, wie's ja von Anfang an befürchtet habe, von Corona auf äh Weltkrieg umschulen oder auf Ukraine, Fachleute und Russland Fachleute.
Dann haben wir natürlich schon mittelschweres Problem. Ich frage mich nur.
Ist ist es möglich diesen Problem zu begegnen, indem man dann diese Sender wirklich am ähm.
Am am Senden hindert an der an der Vermittlung ihrer Inhalte hindert oder bestärkt man damit wiederum diese Verschwörungstheorie und was mich da am meisten so auseinander durcheinander bringt, ist halt zu sagen so na ja.
Wenn ich die jetzt ihren Quatsch verbreiten lasse.
Dann stärkt das die Verschwörungstheorie, weil die die Verschwörungstheorie verbreiten. Wenn ich die am verbreiten hindere, dann stärkt das die Verschwörungstheorie, weil.
Ähm man sie ja an der Verbreitung hindert,
Also warte, mach's, machste falsch, wenn du mit Leuten interagierst, die halt nicht in der Lage sind äh sich ein ein Weltbild aus Fakten zu konstruieren, sondern aus irgendwie spannend klingenden Sätzen.
Insofern, ich hätte, glaube ich, kein oder ich hätte wahrscheinlich ein geringeres Problem mit dieser Maßnahme, wenn ich eine Hoffnung hätte, dass sie irgendeinen Effekt hätte. Da ich diese Hoffnung aber auch schon längst aufgegeben habe,
kann ich mich für diese Maßnahme nicht so wirklich erwärmen. Verstehste?
Mhm. Ist ein sehr nachvollziehbar, ne. Ich meine, es ist es ist etwas, was so ein Konflikt in einem auslöst so und ähm mag das auch an mir, ne, dass man einfach in so einer,
Notsituation natürlich gerne äh so im Dunkeln zu jedem Dingen greift, was irgendwie aussieht wie ein Hammer. Und ähm,
aber dann auch erstmal nicht so eine klare äh Strategie hat oder geschweige denn sich in dem Moment ähm viel drum kümmert, was jetzt irgendwie eigentlich das Richtige ist.
Ja oder wie's was mit Prozesse vorschreiben, wie es zu laufen hat, sondern man will einfach nur reagieren, man will das Richtige tun, man will Schaden abwenden.
Und dann geht's oft auch einfach mal nur um Geschwindigkeit und,
gar nicht mal, um einen rechtsstaatlichen Prozess. Das ist natürlich genau das, was wir eigentlich durch einen Rechtsstaat sicherstellen wollen, ne. Wir wollen, dass eben diese Prozesse sind. Wir wollen aber auch manchmal, dass diese Prozesse langsam sind,
weil eine Verlangsamung oft auch zur Reflexion äh einlädt in dem Moment, wo mehr Parteien äh eingebunden werden müssen und
ein Für und Wider äh ausspielen und das Ganze sich dann erstmal so entwickelt, bis es dann an einen Punkt kommt, wo,
Entscheidung kommt, so machen wir das jetzt. Das das ist ja auch gewünscht, damit eben ein Staat nicht überreagiert. Und äh das wird natürlich in dem Moment sehr schwierig,
wo hm man ihn in in so eine Kriegssituation kommt. Jetzt kann man natürlich argumentieren, ja, aber wir sind ja gar nicht im Krieg.
Das kann man natürlich so sehen. Das kann man aber auch anders sehen. Also unser Wirtschaftsminister hat es ja selber schon so gesagt, ja? Wir sind.
Eine Kriegspartei und ich meine, das lässt sich auch nicht so ganz von der Hand äh weisen. Ich meine, wir schaufeln da einfach äh tonnenweise Unterstützung jeglicher Form bis hin zu Waffen hin,
Äh er hat's dann noch eingeschränkt auf wir sind eine Wirtschaftskriegspartei oder vielleicht das auch nur noch weiter erklärt. So oder zumindest dem noch mal einen anderen Namen gegeben, was primär unsere Rolle jetzt gerade ist.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz äh sind wir eben in so einem Krieg, also in einem Zustand der totalen Auseinandersetzung, in der
automatisch erstmal sagt, wir müssen jetzt irgendwie Schaden von uns nehmen und natürlich nimmt man diese Propaganda primär
als schädlich war. Ist ja eigentlich auch. Das ist, glaube ich, vollkommen unbestritten, dass das irgendwie schädlich ist. Ob's jetzt etwas hilft, es äh wegzunehmen. Gut,
Darüber kann man debattieren. Wahrscheinlich nicht. Habe gerade wieder irgendwelche Videos gesehen von irgendwelchen queren,
Denker, Honsos, die da in Dresden jetzt irgendwie mit russischen Flaggen rumlaufen und dann so ja, ist ja irgendwie hier wieder alles Propaganda und so und die der Russe ist doch ganz gut und so. Das das war so vorhersehbar, ne? Nur.
Wär's halt auch passiert, wenn RTN schon jahrelang.
Diese ganze Propaganda hier äh reingeworfen hätte. Ist schwierig. Wir wir loben uns für ein offenes System und wir finden es ja auch gut und richtig und ist auch so, ja? Das,
dass man einen einen offenen Diskurs haben muss über ähm.
Prozesse, über Recht, über was Gesetze sein sollte, was unsere ethisch-moralischen,
Vorstellungen und Überzeugungen und auch der Wandel über die Zeit so ähm mit uns macht, was wie wir uns kollektiv verhalten sollten.
Das erfordert halt eine offene Gesellschaft, eine offene Gesellschaft erfordert einen äh auch ein offenes,
Mediensystem. Nur ist es halt jetzt so ein bisschen auch wie so mit dem Internet an sich, dass wir eben sehen, dass dass es dafür auch einen Preis gibt und der Preis ist natürlich eine extreme Verletzlichkeit,
öffentlichkeit für Leute, die eben bewusst mit,
Lügen, Fake, et cetera äh da rein agieren und eine Disruption dieses Diskurses befördern. Und das ist natürlich schon etwas,
Dass man sich wehren sollte und,
Die einfache äh der einfache Ansatz ist nur so ja, wir müssen ja nur genug die Wahrheit sagen und wir müssen ja nur genug äh.
Dass die Banken und so weiter, nur habe ich so den Eindruck, damit können wir auch nicht so richtig weit oder zumindest nicht so weit, wie wir wollen.
Weißt du, was ich äh halt was ich schwierig finde bei so wenn man jetzt insbesondere bei Menschen aus dem Osten Deutschlands, den sogenannten neuen Bundesländern? Ähm dass die.
Sage ich mal potenziell.
Wie soll man das also irgendwie nicht notwendigerweise pro russisch sind, aber wenn denen halt die eine Hälfte ihres Lebens erzählt wurde, Russland ist der große Bruder,
dann äh gibt's auf einmal eine Revolution, dann wird denen nur noch erzählt, Russland ist schlecht und böse und die aber gleichzeitig in dieser neuen Welt,
weniger Verankerung, weniger Identifikation und auch weniger ökonomische Perspektiven haben.
Dann ist das ein, dass die dann potenziell äh Russland.
Sich nicht vorstellen können, dass Russland jetzt irgendwie ein Krieg angefangen hat oder irgendwie so was die da eben für einen Quatsch reden. Ähm.
Das liegt ja jetzt nicht daran, dass es eher Tee gibt, sondern es liegt daran, dass die eine im Leben eine Erfahrung gemacht haben, dass sie erst sehr stark von Russland geprägt wurden.
Sie auch längere Zeit ihres Lebens, sagen wir mal, schon durchaus angelogen wurden,
von einer Regierung, ja, auch das ist ja eine Erfahrung, äh die die potenziell
Also, die dir potenziell das Vertrauen nimmt in der nächsten Regierung noch mal zu vertrauen. Erst recht,
Diese neue Regierung Bundesrepublik Deutschland dir irgendwie nicht die blühenden Landschaften bei dir im Vorgarten äh organisiert hat, die dir mal versprochen waren und du dich in dieser neuen,
Regierungs,
in diesem neuen Land, äh indem du dich jetzt plötzlich befindest, auch einfach nicht ausreichend berücksichtigt fühlst und ich ich glaube tatsächlich, dass das andere Zusammenhänge sind als jetzt nur
zu viel Russia Today geguckt. Also haben sie auch,
Aber ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt sich dadurch lindern lässt der Zustand dieser Menschen. Ob das nicht doch viel, viel schlimmere, viel, viel länger und tiefer sitzende ähm Misstrauenskeime sind.
Also das mag eine Rolle spielen, aber das darauf jetzt zurückzuführen ist mir dann auch zu einfach. Zumal vielen dieser Leute nicht jetzt im eigentlichen Sinne schlecht geht. Also dieses Märchen des der der wirtschaftlich komplett äh abgehängt. Das lässt sich so nicht,
halten, weil du hast halt in diesem ganzen Querdenker äh Gemenge halt auch eine ganze Menge Leute, die sehr wohl leben.
Eine Kreuzfahrt mit der AIDA, da wird dir dann aber ganz viel erzählt.
Na ja, ich.
Will ich jetzt gar nicht groß irgendwie meine Schlüsse draus ziehen, ja? Ich rede eigentlich auch nur von einem äh.
Bisschen übernutztes Wort, aber dieses Spannungsfeld, so dieses diese innere Zersplitterung, die die ich da auch empfinde und ich ehrlich gesagt, ich habe da einfach keine gute Antwort drauf. Ich kann ich kann äh.
Beide Seiten da gut verstehen, ja? Aber mir kommt das halt so ein bisschen vor wie äh.
Quantenphysik und und und Gravitationslehre so beides hat irgendwie was wahres an sich. Ist aber irgendwie nicht kompatibel miteinander.
Das ist ein schönes äh Fazit
Wir haben noch in der IT also es gibt ja unterschiedliche Bemühungen der ukrainischen Cyber-Armee und es werden auch einige.
Also durchaus enormes äh verübt ja gerade den ein oder anderen Hack,
auch dieser Medienaufsichts Struktur der Ross Kombination oder wie die heißt 800 Gigabyte musste ich das sieden um diese Daten zu verbreiten, die ich größtenteils nicht äh lesen kann ähm,
Also da passiert ein bisschen was, gleichzeitig glaube ich bisher hält so ein bisschen die These, dass das nicht notwendigerweise ähm.
Krieg entscheiden wird und gleichzeitig hält sich potenziell erstmal die These, dass alle ja eigentlich versuchen.
Zu dem Russisch zu der russischen Bevölkerung durchzudringen. Ja, alle feiern hier äh Arnold Schwarzenegger, der ja wirklich ein Wahnsinnsvideo gemacht hat, ganz toll, also wirklich irre.
Ich weiß einfach nicht genau, wie wie gut und wie weit es dieses Video nach Russland geschafft hat. Deswegen haben sich ja jetzt ein paar.
Entwickler offenbar eine hm Idee ausgedacht, wie man in in Russland vielleicht Gehör finden könnte.
Du hast dich damit auseinandergesetzt.
Du meinst ähm der der der Protest über MPM-Pakete?
Hätte ich jetzt auch nicht gedacht, dass das noch mal die Keilzellen des Widerstands wird.
Ist es auch nicht, kann ich dich beruhigen. Nee, ist ja äh eigentlich ist das eher so ein,
Auswuchs würde ich sagen, ja. Das,
wir hatten das doch glaube ich hier auch schon mal diskutiert, ne, dass so äh Fehler in Open-Source-Paketen,
schnell mal in Programme reinrutscht. Das hatten wir hier mit dieser Lok for Jay Geschichte, aber ich meine mich zu erinnern, dass wir das auch schon mal mit so einem Javascript-Tool äh auch schon mal hatten.
Also grundsätzlich, dass das sich äh Open Source Bibliotheken, Reger, Verwendungen,
erfreuen, weil hier schon mal äh das ein oder andere Mal Thema und ich glaube dieses NPM-Ökosystem, also das Ökosystem hat ja äh ähm eine ganz besondere,
Ähm ein ganz besonderen Hang zu Paketen. Also du du setzt dir da irgendwie dein no JS äh Ding auf,
Denkst du linkst jetzt mal drei Pakete, die die Linken aber sechsunddreißig andere jeweils und rucki zucki hast du auf einmal 100 Pakete und entsprechend,
haben hier um dieser Sache Herr zu werden gibt's ja dann so eigene Befehle wie NPM Audit,
wo wo der quasi sich für diese ganzen Pakete, die du dir da eingetreten hast, wieder die Wein-Nobility Informationen holt, um um irgendwie den ganzen,
noch ähm auf der auf der Höhe der Zeit zu halten, weil du,
im Prinzip gar keinen Überblick hast, was jetzt wieder andere Pakete, die du gelingt hast, sich wiederum für die Pendencies holen und da bist du in so einer absoluten Dependency-Hölle und wenn du bei einem,
No-Jhares-Projekt, was du dir einen Monat nicht angeguckt hast, einfach mal NPM-Outfit machst und der sagt dann, ja hier äh vierhundert Pakete haben Updates ähm.
Acht davon sind Sicherheits-Updates. Das ist so ein äh völlig äh normale Zeit in dieser MPM-Welt und da gab's vor vielen Jahren mal einen,
Entwickler, der so ein bisschen,
aufgeschrieben hat, wie er diese MPM-Welt übernehmen würde, nämlich dass er irgendwie ein einfaches Paket schreibt für.
Buntes also farbiges Outpuk Output in den Konsolenlogs. Ja also ein Feature wo du dann in der,
halt Farben hast und besser die bangen kannst und dass er dieses Paket dann.
Eben als Merch Request in viele andere reinbringen würde,
quasi zu sagen, guck mal hier schön jetzt ich habe das Output bei den beim verbessert und alle würden das natürlich wahrscheinlich dankend annehmen und dann würde er irgendwann hingehen und dieses Paket böse machen.
Wenn es eine ausreichend große Installationsbasis hat. Das war eine Fantasiegeschichte, aber ähm sie war zu erschreckend und zu überzeugend, als dass man jetzt nicht schon das ein oder andere Mal auch,
ja Angriffe in NPM-Paketen äh gesehen hat oder natürlich auch so Sachen wie Browser,
Plugins, wo wir ja auch die Forschung ähm schon öfter auf dem Kongress hatten, dass die dann aufgekauft werden, dass es dann irgendwann einfach um die Installationsbasis geht und gar nicht mehr wirklich um die,
Funktionalität, aber ich schweife ab, was ist bei passiert?
Ich weiß jetzt übrigens wieder, was was der erste Fall war. Das war nämlich gar nicht äh dass der Code ähm verändert wurde, sondern ich glaube der.
Das einfach offline genommen.
Er ist einfach offline genommen, genau, weil er irgendwie, ja, es ist mir zu viel Arbeit hier irgendwie, verdiene ja eh keine Kohle mit irgendwie. Ich nehme das jetzt einfach mal weg und dann brach halt alles sofort. Wobei man jetzt sagen muss,
Nicht so, dass es die vorherige Version, mit der alle glücklich waren, nicht noch gegeben hätte. Das eigentliche Problem ist das Setup dieser äh Softwaresysteme, die halt immer so ah ja, ich mache mal Update, Bro, dann ist irgendwie alles frisch, dann ist irgendwie alles immer in der Annahme, dann ist alles besser so
und dann äh äh
update ich auch mehr oder weniger direkt in mein Deployment, also das was dann auch wirklich live ähm mit den Daten oder den Usern im Web oder so weiter äh interagiert und niemand hat sich so viel
Gedanken darüber gemacht, was denn nun mal wäre, wenn so ein Update irgendwo, na ja, nicht den gewünschten Zielen äh.
Du meinst CID.
Als sie die.
Development. Nee, Continuous Integration, Continuis Deployment. CID Pipeline.
Ja, also es.
Anderen auch auch bekannt als äh Jolo.
Genau, also man,
Das ist ja seit seit vielen Jahren sozusagen, also am Anfang waren diese Pakete. Dann waren das nützlich. Dann hat man die benutzt. Dann wurden's immer mehr. Dann wurde es schwierig, das zu händeln. Dann kamen diese ganzen Paketmanager. Durch die Paketmanager wurde es dann alles wieder einfach und dann so ach so einfach ist das, nehmen wir mal ganz viele mit rein.
Es läuft natürlich dann der Entwicklung auch irgendwann so ein bisschen hinterher und in dem Moment, wo dann einfach so ein kleines, wichtiges oder vielleicht auch nicht so wichtiges Tool einfach komplett fehlt so, dann bricht schon alles auseinander und wenn man eben nicht unterschieden hat zwischen einem Testsystem, wo man erstmal,
ob das nach diesem Update auch noch alles das das tut, was es soll, ja äh und dem, was man wirklich einsetzt, dann hat man halt schnell ein Problem und das ist aber leider sehr oft so.
Und jetzt gibt's natürlich den Krieg und durch diesen Krieg fühlen sich dann auch wiederum viele Individuen,
Berufen jetzt in irgendeiner Form, in Anführungsstrichen was gegen den Krieg zu tun, ja? Also irgendeine Form von Protest und dann greifst du natürlich zu dem
was du hast, greifst du zu dem, was du kannst, zu dem was äh
dir im Zugriff ist so und manche Leute können's nur laut auf der Straße rausschreien, andere haben vielleicht politische Einflussmöglichkeiten, Entwickler haben in PM-Pakete.
Oder auch andere Pakete. In diesem Fall war's ein NPM-Paket mit dem äh flüssigen Namen Note IPC.
Ich vermute jetzt mal das macht irgendwie Inter-Prozess-Kommunikation, was auch immer äh das dann in dem Fall genau getan hat. Auf jeden Fall der Entwickler war so dermaßen gepisst von der ganzen Situation, dass er am 7. März,
Ein Update von seinem Modul was wohl in sehr vielen Programmen zum Einsatz kommt eben äh rausgebracht hat was.
Im Prinzip so eine digitale Bombe war,
und was er dann gemacht hat, war also etwas einfach so auf dem System, wo denn dieser Code aktiv wird. Man hört schon auf IPC, das hat so was mit Networking zu tun und so und er hat also dann,
Zugriff auch auf IP-Adressen in dem Fall. Schaut sich diese IP-Adressen an, macht dann ein Loop-up. Also es gibt so die Möglichkeit zu sagen,
Ich habe hier eine IP-Adresse, kann mir jemand sagen woher die kommt oder welchem,
Provider, die zugeteilt ist und kann ich daraus in irgendeiner Form eine Zuordnung zu einem Land machen. Man hat das oft, wenn man irgendwie irgendwo hinklickt
Dann gibt's ja diese äh Streaming Barrieren, wenn man die EU verlassen hat, dann kannst du irgendwie an deinem Streaming-Account nicht mehr teilnehmen, weil halt jemand sich diese IP-Adresse anschaut und sagt, na ja du bist ja gar nicht in Deutschland oder du bist ja nicht in der EU
Und genau so was hat er auch gemacht und hat er dann geguckt so ist das eine IP-Adresse, die in Russland oder in Weißrussland liegt und wenn ja,
Ding total rope gelaufen und hat irgendwie angefangen alle ihm irgendeiner Form zugänglichen Dateien zu löschen.
Kann man machen. Äh gute Idee eigentlich nicht so, weil erstens,
Kriegst du damit auch nicht aufgehalten. Ja du hast vielleicht so deine persönliche Rage oder deine eigene Hilflosigkeit in gewisser Hinsicht bearbeitet, weil das Gefühl hatte, du tust jetzt was und du bestrafst jetzt die bösen Russen,
die du äh eindeutig identifiziert hast anhand einer IP-Adresse.
Wie man das ja heutzutage macht. Guten Tag, zeigen Sie mir mal Ihre IP-Adresse. Ähm.
Hat aber natürlich überhaupt nicht einmal auch nur um die Ecke gedacht, was das eben auch für einen Schaden,
anrichten kann, der jetzt überhaupt nicht intendiert ist, weil das ist halt einfach keine gute Inteligence, einfach nur diesen einen Look ab einer IP-Adresse zu machen. Zeigt sich dann auch,
irgendeine äh US-amerikanische NGO, die in Weißrussland aktiv ist, da einen Server äh hat von diesem Problem betrieben war. Ist natürlich auch deren Problem, weil die wiederum ihr Setup nicht im Griff hatten, aber
hatten wir ja schon darüber geredet ja und das halt so eine äh Gruppe, die halt irgendwie Meldungen von Whistleblowern einsammelt, was halt irgendwie ein Weißrussland äh scheiße läuft,
Schlechte Backup-Strategie, Ergebnis 2.500 Meldungen irgendwie seit 2014 irgendwie alles hops genommen worden von diesem Tool,
Also da kamen jetzt mehrere Sachen zusammen, aber ist halt ähm ja am Ende gibt's dann nur unglückliche Menschen.
Also ich ich sehe hier gerade mir mal äh auf GitHub den Code an, ne und also ich will nichts sagen. Also er hatte ja offenbar irgendwie äh ein bisschen äh Office katet, aber jemand hat den da mal in an obfürskated,
gepastet es geht halt erstmal es ist so typisch also erstmal macht er auf AP Punkt IP Gio Location dot IO einen Rique,
wie sich das für Gitup gehört ist natürlich der Apequi mit da drin geht jetzt an der Stelle auch nicht anders, aber er hat ihn halt mit drin den äh dann,
wird äh das Jason erstmal.
OTF 8 und dann guckt er, wenn in Country Name äh Russia oder Belarus vorkommt ähm,
dann löscht er im aktuellen Verzeichnis dann im und dann im Grandparent und dann im Rot,
Wo du auch denkst so, ey komm, da kann man sich auch einen schöneren Loop schreiben, äh weil wenn du Pech hast, bricht dir das Ding ja ab, weil du gar kein Grandpoint hast oder du hast noch fünf dazwischen, die du jetzt nicht kaputt gemacht hast. Also irgendwie so ein bisschen äh.
Noch nicht mal besonders elegant für so ein für so ein Cyber-Party Sahne Bombe. Da muss man sagen, da dat kann man eleganter schreiben.
Gut, aber.
Ne muss ich jetzt aber sagen.
Zumal die einfache, also ein einfacher Fix wäre, äh dass dieser API-Punkt IPG-Location dort IO diesen RPQ ungültig machen,
entweder immer rusher zurückgeben oder gar nicht. Jedenfalls äh ähm ja alles irgendwie ich weiß nicht, bin nicht so überzeugt.
Es ist auch ein Zeichen von von Hilflosigkeit.
Ja, hat er sich hatte wie wie ist es denn mit dem Paket weitergegangen.
Ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Haben noch nicht, haben die meisten noch nicht geupdatet.
Also äh ich glaube dürfte wahrscheinlich wohl mittlerweile zurückgezogen worden sein, aber habe ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht so verfolgt.
Okay, also haben wir euch vor gewarnt.
Insgesamt gibt es aber so beim Cyberwall jetzt nicht so viel Neues, äh also die ViAsat Modems waren kaputt. Ich glaube, das hatte ich in der letzten Sendung schon gesagt. Ähm,
Das BSI denkt sich, oh wir waren mal vor Kasperski, dem äh Virenscanner. Und auch das.
Weißt du, also,
Also. Jetzt haben die USA schon vor Jahren gewarnt und den für ihre Behörden verboten.
Das war meine Reaktion darauf, dass Kaspersky als allererstes irgendsoeine US Malware bei sich in den Signaturen drin hatte. Ähm.
Sich auch an der Analyse irgendwie beteiligt hatte, wenn da könnte jetzt sein, dass man äh meine Erinnerung mich da ein bisschen äh täuscht, aber ähm.
Die Überlegungen vielleicht zu sagen, okay ich möchte.
Eine Software vom Typ Virenscanner nicht unbedingt auf den Rechnern meiner Behörden haben, wenn sie nicht aus meinem Land kommt, wo,
sie im Zweifelsfall von meinem Geheimdienst infiltriert ist. Das kann man ja zumindest noch nachvollziehen.
Jahre her. Jetzt kommt dieser äh Russland-Ukraine-Krieg und.
Den BSI fällt ja fällt Jahre später plötzlich ein so ja wir waren jetzt aber mal davor äh Kaspersit zu verwenden,
ist nur die Frage, also okay, warum machen sie diese Warnung aus einer technischen Perspektive sind Virenscanner sehr, sehr ähm.
Tief in das Windows-System eingebunden und haben dort relativ weitreichende Zugangsrechte,
diese Zugangsrechte könnten sie natürlich auch ähm missbrauchen, ja? Noch hinzu kommt,
also absichtlich missbrauchen oder auch die Virenscanner könnten,
von schlechter Qualität sein und ihrerseits selber wiederum eine Schwachstelle haben und da sie aber mit mit sehr hohen Privilegien im System laufen,
sind sie eine sehr lohnende Angriffsfläche, also was ironisch klingt, aber heckst du den Virenscanner? Dann hast du natürlich Glück,
der hat eine große Angriffsfläche, weil er ja auch alles scannt. Das heißt, wenn du irgendeine Datei hast, du kannst sicher sein, wenn der Virenscanner vorbeikommt, der schaut sich die an.
Wenn du jetzt in irgendeiner Weise, in dem, was er mit dir macht, eine ähm Schwachstelle hast, dann und du übernimmst diesen Prozess,
dann hast du direkt Systemprivilegien, also ist es auch eine Angriffsfläche auf technischer Ebene.
Man sieht auch manchmal Angriffe auf solche Virenscanner.
Aber warum geht das WSI jetzt hin und sagt vor allem öffentlich auch für Verbraucher nutzt nicht diesen Virenscanner? Was machen denn jetzt die Menschen?
Diesen Virenscanner nun mal bezahlt haben, weil sie zu Weihnachten von ihrem Enkel die ähm.
Die die Lizenz für ein Jahr geschenkt bekommen haben oder so was, ja, weil der dann ruhiger schläft.
Haben die Menschen, grade jetzt die Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher, werden die jetzt gehackt vom Russen?
Das halte ich dann doch für eine relativ unwahrscheinliches Szenario. Ja ähm also,
im Militär, in der ähm in der in den Behörden, in den kritischen Infrastrukturen kann man sich über solche Dinge ja potenziell mal Gedanken machen,
Aber jetzt eine öffentliche Warnung an die Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher rauszugeben, frage ich mich echt, wie sollen die denn darauf reagieren? Was soll denn da jetzt passieren? Was ist eine erwartete Konsequenz von dieser Warnung?
Das Beste, was der Rat ist ja noch nicht mal schlecht. Ich glaube, das BSI hat auch geschrieben, mach den Quatsch aus und nutzt den Windows Defender, also den.
Windows zehn. Ja ähm.
Ich habe im im Deutschlandfunk dazu ein Interview gegeben und da habe ich gesagt, ja der Rat, den Windows Defender zu verwenden und keinen anderen zusätzlichen Virenscanner, äh den halte ich für äh sinnvoll
ja und dann sagte der Manfred Kläuber von Computer Kommunikation, der kommt jetzt aber auch selten vor, dass der Couscous Computerclub Microsoft Produkt empfiehlt
Und dann habe ich dir gesagt, na ja, ich meine, wenn du doch eh schon für Microsoft Windows bezahlt hast, ich kann den Leuten ja jetzt nicht weißt du, wenn ich das BSI dafür kritisiere zu sagen, die Leute sollen sich
D installieren. Ähm.
Wer bin ich dann zu sagen, installiert euch direkt am besten noch Windows mit und macht was weiß ich, irgendein anderes System drauf. Wenn die Leute ja auch nicht fröhlich haben mit. Ich denke ehrlich gesagt, für ganz normale Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher,
die jetzt nicht notwendigerweise den russischen Staat fürchten besteht überhaupt gar kein Handlungsbedarf,
Wenn du jetzt irgendwie den russischen Staat fürchtest und es irgendein.
Irgendeine Vermutung gäbe, dass ausgerechnet Kaspersky sich jetzt von Putin infiltrieren lässt, was auch wiederum relativ unwahrscheinlich ist. Also ich glaube, das war einfach nicht nicht nennenswert überlegt. Äh bin ich ganz ehrlich.
Russland will sich vom Internet abkoppeln, wollten sie auch früher schon mal haben wir schon mal drüber gesprochen ähm.
Sind sie nicht so richtig weit mitgekommen.
Gekommen, ja und dann brauchen sie auch kein Internet mehr, also,
das äh äh es geht glaube ich eher darum ihre Zensurmöglichkeiten zu konzentrieren und halt die Verwendung staatlicher DNS-Server und sonstigen zu ähm.
Zu erzwingen, aber insgesamt scheint mir und das habe ich ja in der ersten Sendung, wo wir darüber gesprochen haben, schon so gesagt, wir,
es die Probleme der Welt sind grade wirklich andere. Ja und das sage ich als jemand, der die Probleme,
seit äh über einem Jahrzehnt äh sehr, sehr genau beruflich,
darin involviert ist und so weiter ich sehe jetzt bei aller, auch es ist ja mehr los im im.
Enormes Aktivitäten in ähm.
Ukrainische Cyber-Armee, russische Angriffe, die NATO meldet, es hätte Versuche der russischen,
russischen Hacker gegeben, die NATO zu hacken,
mir so frage, so Leute, selbstverständlich, ich wäre enttäuscht, wenn ihr es nicht jeden Tag versuchen würden. Und wenn sie's in letzter Zeit nicht versucht haben, dann würde ich mir an eurer Stelle Gedanken machen, A,
Warum nicht? Sind sie vielleicht schon drin, ja? Äh oder ähm haben sie jetzt aufgehört oder sehen wir es nicht? Ja, aber jetzt zu sagen ähm.
Also davon auszugehen, dass gerade keine Angriffe stattfinden, da würde ich eigentlich von ausgehen, weil sie im Zweifelsfall längst da drin hängen. Also ich bin da das ist.
Als jemand, der mehr in diesem Thema drin hängt, bin ich halt so ein bisschen enttäuscht davon, wie.
Du hängst da schon drin in der NATO.
Das I, ja das ist halt Aufgabe. NATO ist äh Hacker-Grundschule. Nein, Quatsch. Die ähm,
Also als jemand, der sich beruflich mit dem Thema ja auseinandersetzt und durchaus diese Fälle auch sieht, muss ich trotzdem sagen, dass im Moment immer noch mir.
Andere Entwicklungen sehr viel mehr Sorge bereiten, zum Beispiel ein Krieg äh oder ein Wirtschaftskrieg, ähm.
Es kann immer sein, dass sich, äh das habe ich bei der letzten Sendung auch schon gesagt, dass sich das schlagartig ändert. Mhm, aber das, worüber bis heute berichtet wird,
und welche Fälle da vorgefallen sind bis auf einzelne wie dieser Angriff ist eben und es ist erstaunlich wie viel Aufmerksamkeit das dann doch in der in den Medien äh bekommt.
Macht sich halt gut.
Dann gibt's noch eine kurze, kurze Sache zu dieser ganzen Ukrainegeschichte, die wo ich auch leider also wo ich auch wieder herzlich äh gequält lachen musste und zwar habe ich einen Witz im Internet gelesen.
Wirklich, oh Gott.
Ja, ich habe einen Witz. Ich werde jetzt irgendwie ich lese jetzt einen Witz vorteilen. Immer mehr ukrainische Geflüchtete kommen ins deutsche Schulsystem.
Ja, da ist natürlich ein immenser Nachholbedarf, gerade bei digitalen Plattformen, Videounterricht und Lerninhalten, aber wir helfen, wo wir können, so einer der Geflüchteten im Interview.
Findest du nicht witzig?
Und das es ist halt nicht witzig. Es ist so. Ne und das und die ähm wie war das denn, die äh ukrainische Konsulin lehnt eine Integration der Flüchtlingskinder ins deutsche Schulsystem ab?
Zu schlecht ist und zu fremd. Ja also die die Ukraine sieht in den Willkommensklassen keine Lösung,
sondern fordert Unterricht auf ukrainisch nach ukrainischen Lehrplänen. Ja, weil sie die Kinder jetzt nicht den Kindern nicht nachhaltig ihre Zukunft ruinieren wollen, nur weil die in Deutschland sind.
Irgendwie äh das Internet äh immer noch den Leuten äh vorenthalten wird und die die Lehrpläne irgendwie aus den letzten Jahrtausend sind.
Ja und vor allem die Ukraine schafft das halt auch noch einen Onlineunterricht anzubieten im Krieg äh das Deutschland noch nicht mal zufrieden Zeiten gelingt so etwas zu machen.
Zwei Jahre Pandemie kriegt Deutschland das nicht hin. Und die Ukraine sagt so, okay Leute, wir können verstehen, wir können verstehen, wenn ihr euch in Deutschland in Sicherheit bringt, aber ne, Vorsicht, Schule.
Die Schulen sind schlecht.
Passt auf mit die Schule.
Wollen ja nicht, dass unsere Kinder verrohen und verwahrlosen. Im Ausland.
Ja echt so. Ihr habt da noch einen der noch ein ganzes Leben vor euch? Jetzt schmeißt es doch nicht weg.
Oh Mann.
Dann gibt's noch eine Geschichte, die wir ja auch äh einige Zeit begleitet haben.
Genau der Drachenlord.
Der sogenannte eigentlich Rainer Winkler äh wir haben die Story hier glaube ich schon mal etwas ausführlicher dargestellt, ne und ähm vielleicht verlinken wir nochmal auf die Sendung, aber,
So in der Summe, es handelt sich halt um einen Menschen, der,
Auf YouTube seine eigene Show gemacht hat und naja, damit so einen mäßigen Erfolg hatte. Es wurde aber irgendwie geschafft hat, darüber über Werbeeinnahmen auch ähm so ein Einkommen damit zu realisieren. Andere,
Fähigkeiten und Tätigkeiten hat er nicht so richtig betrieben.
Ist dann halt äh mit der Zeit durch verschiedenste Vorfälle zu so einem Hass-Objekt geworden und es hat sich halt mittlerweile so eine eigene Kult darum,
gebildet äh unter dem etwas lässigen Begriff Drachen geben. Also er hat sich glaube ich als Drachenlord selber bezeichnet. Hat so einen Heavy Mettler und.
Na ja, auf jeden Fall äh in den letzten Jahren ist das einfach total,
eskaliert. Es gibt da mittlerweile zehntausende Leute, die sich da irgendwie zusammentun und irgendwie der Meinung sind, es wäre
und angemessen diesen Menschen sein ohnehin schon etwas beschränktes Leben zur Hölle zu machen, indem sie ihn halt online, aber halt auch offline vor Ort
beobachten und ausgetrickst haben und beschimpfen und beleidigen und hinters Licht führen und was nicht alles. Die Story ist wirklich endlos und furchtbar,
Ich finde, jetzt gab es den letzten Oktober,
Eine Verhandlung dazu, weil's natürlich im Rahmen verschiedener Auseinandersetzungen auch zu Körperverletzungen gekommen sein soll, an denen er beteiligt wurde mit anderen Worten, Erstand vor Gericht.
Also der der Hintergrund muss man immer äh vielleicht noch ein bisschen äh in seiner Dramatik erörtern. Dieses dieses Haus, in dem der da wohnt, ist eine Pilgerstätte verarschtgeigen.
Gewesen und ähm ja und die sind da äh zu jeder Zeit hingekommen,
ähm haben ihn dann da provoziert, weil der natürlich ähm.
Das ist irgendwie damals nicht besonders sozial integrierter Mensch mitm mit vielen Freunden oder so, sondern er wohnt ja in irgend so einem Haus, hat jetzt wahrscheinlich auch nicht das
einfachste Leben gehabt und dann hat er halt den ganzen Tag einen Tag aus irgendwelche Vögel vor der Tür. Die ignorierte natürlich irgendwann oder macht einen ähm.
Mach den Vorhang zu, ja? Dann komm aber natürlich äh die sind ja dahin gekommen, um was zu erleben.
Das heißt, die provozieren immer mehr Reaktionen. Die werfen, was aufs Grundstück, die sprühen an die Garagentor, die klettern über den Zaun. Hauptsache es passiert etwas. So, der Mensch
mit dem sie das machen lässt hat das seit Jahren über sich ergehen und ähm.
In den schlechten Momenten seines Lebens äh reagiert er dann halt mit Gewalt, weil er die Schnauze voll hat und äh,
schmeißt irgendwas oder schlägt einen und dann wiederum sind Leute offenbar mit dem Ziel und das war ja in diesem Fall auch tatsächlich so, dass sie gesagt haben, wir bringen denen in den Knast.
Und wir provozieren den jetzt, dass der uns angreift, ja? Und jetzt hat er uns geschlagen, super, das ist das das xte Mal, dass er jemanden geschlagen hat und jetzt.
Gehen wir zur Polizei und zeigen den an wegen Körperverletzung und die Aussage ist ungefähr so wir sind,
400 Kilometer durch die Bundesrepublik gefahren, äh um bei dem Typen vor der Tür Mäzchen zu machen und irgendwas übern Zaun zu werfen und Arschloch zu rufen und dann hat der uns einfach gehauen.
So und und dann freuen sie sich, dass der Typ, weil er's weil er offenbar unter diesem Druck mehrfach ähm äh derartige Reaktionen gezeigt hat und da eben auch öfter eben nicht mit Strafe rausgekommen ist, dass er jetzt eben.
Eine Bewährungsstrafe bekommen hat. Ähm währenddessen muss man ja auch sagen, die Leute in diesem Dorf als Schauerberg,
die hatten natürlich auch kein Bock auf die Arschgeigen, die da den ganzen Tag waren und haben sich irgendwie ja auch,
gewünscht, dass der Typ aufhört. Die Polizei hatte keinen Bock mehr, den zu schützen, weil sie gesagt haben, wir sind hier eigentlich Bullen in als Schauerberg, weil wir chillen wollen und nicht, weil wir den ganzen Tag äh irgendwie,
nur weil dieser Rainer Winkler ins Internet spricht. So, was der ins Internet spricht, ist größtenteils ähm sagen wir mal relativ belanglos,
kann man sich auch nicht lange angucken, außer man ist irgendein Idiot, der meint, er müsste denen irgendwie.
Müsste sich zum Lebensinhalten machen, sich mit mit mit diesen Trivialitäten eines ähm.
Ja eines Menschen auseinanderzusetzen, der jetzt nicht besonders interessante Dinge erzählt, ja,
den irgendwie fertig zu machen. Das finde ich wirklich ziemlich schwach und,
In diesem ersten Verfahren, über das wir hier auch berichtet haben, hat die Richterin ja gesagt, wir möchten, dass sie aufhören zu youtuben.
Hat die Richterin dem ernsthaft nahegelegt und ihm dann auch negativ ausgelegt, als er seine dazu keine Bereitschaft hat, erkennen lassen.
Das finde ich schon wirklich faszinierend, ja? Also wenn ihr stell dir mal vor Tim,
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen stehst du vor Gericht, die sagen, ja hören sie mal auf hier mit mit Podcasten. Dann äh dann äh dann kommen auch nicht die ganze Zeit Menschen zu ihnen nach Hause, die sie belästigen.
Finde ich äh finde ich schon wirklich faszinierend, dass äh dass,
Also der Typ ist nervig. Ich kann auch verstehen, warum man den nicht mag, aber genau deswegen guckt man sich ja den auch nicht an. Aber das Letzte, was mir einfallen würde, wäre dahin zu fahren.
Ja, also ich meine,
Hast du verschiedene Fässer aufgemacht? Man muss ja erstmal vielleicht kurz die die Fakten nochmal ich hatte ja gesagt es gab letzten Oktober gab's eine erste Verhandlung und ein auch ein Urteil und dort ist er ja tatsächlich zu zwei Jahren Haft verurteilt worden.
Dager wurde gegen die Berufung eingelegt und diese Berufungsverhandlung, die ist jetzt abgeschlossen worden mit einem neuen Urteil und,
Jetzt ist das halt reduziert worden, Strafmaß auf ein Jahr auf Bewährung. Nicht so lang und nicht so hart.
Und es wurde zwar gesagt, okay hier gefährliche Körperverletzung, ja, aber wir sehen hier eine verminderte äh Schuldfähigkeit, weil vor allem die Geschädigten ihn halt bewusst provoziert hätten.
Weil sie genau wussten, dass er äh sich dann irgendwann auch nicht mehr beherrschen.
Ja und dann gab's auch ein paar andere Sachen, dass irgendwie einer der Hauptbelastungszeugen dann irgendwie äh besoffen vor Gericht äh festgenommen wurde, sich wieder mit Polizisten angelegt hat et cetera
auch nicht unbedingt jetzt dazu beigetragen, dass jetzt diese Position der Elttaler besonders stark war. Also da muss ich auch sagen
Da hat dann jetzt irgendwie das Justizsystem aber auch hm ähm bis man jetzt nicht bewerten, aber reagiert, ne? Also es,
Man hat sich sozusagen das also es war wirklich eine Berufung im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes, weil man ist ja auch nochmal äh rangegangen, hat sich mal wirklich die Situation angeschaut und in gewisser Hinsicht finde ich ein vertretbares Urteil gefällt, weil man kann jetzt auch nicht.
Nachgewiesenen Körperverletzungen komplett absehen deswegen so, ne? Aber jetzt einfach zu sagen so in der Situation.
Die äh irgendwie auch überhaupt nicht okay ist, äh muss einfach in irgendeiner Form das auch berücksichtigt werden und das ist jetzt auch berücksichtigt worden, ne. Mittlerweile hatte er sein Haus verkauft.
Man hat ihn also dazu gebracht äh wegzuziehen. Das Haus wurde danach, also die Gemeinde hat's gekauft, hat's dann sofort abreißen lassen.
Sieht man mal, was was das sozusagen da auch ausgelöst hat in diesem Ort. Also für für die war es einfach wichtig,
einfach alles zu tilgen, was ist so und tauchen immer noch Leute auf und sammeln irgendwelche Steinchen ein, um die dann irgendwie im Internet zu verkaufen. Es ist,
völlig absurd und ähm das haben wir, glaube ich, glaube ich bestimmt auch schon gesagt, dass ich das letzte Mal drüber geredet habe, aber das ist so wirklich für mich immer wieder das Zeichen, dass einfach die die Dummheit und die Gehässigkeit,
Leute nie hoch genug eingeschätzt werden darf,
es einfach jemanden gibt, auf den man sich stürzen kann, wenn's irgendwie äh andere Leute gibt, die für irgendwas schuld sind. Ja und wenn's Schwächere gibt,
Die man draufhauen kann. Dann wird's immer genug Leute geben, die diese Situation auch ausnutzen und sich dabei auch noch,
selber einreden, wie geil sie doch sind. Ja, das war auch so in diesen Protokollen kann es irgendwie immer wieder in der Verhandlung raus, dass diese Leute überhaupt auch gar nicht eingesehen haben, dass ihre Position unter Umständen.
Problematisch ist, ja, weil er ist doch der doofe Drachenlord. Da muss man doch draufhauen.
Ja und dann dann hauen sie dem immer dann haben sie es gibt ja mehrere Aspekte, die sie ihnen dann immer zur Last legen. Der hätte irgendwann einmal in oder hatte er ja offenbar auch dieses kommentieren die Leute auch bei uns dann, wenn man's nur auseinandersetzt. In irgendeinem,
irgendeiner Frage hat irgendjemand gesagt, findest du den Holocaust gut und dann hat er gesagt, ja, also in etwas, was man also.
Im Zweifelsfall als sehr missglückte Ironie.
Im schlimmsten Fall als ein dummes Gelaber von jemandem, der nicht weiß, was er überhaupt redet, äh wahrnehmen kann, hat er gesagt, ein Holocaust wäre eine nice Sache. Ja, äh was net, was natürlich eine.
Ungefähr sage ich mal das Niveau von Äußerung ist, was der Typ sonst auch tätigt. Ja äh von im im Sinne der Reflektiertheit. Ja, das ist kein besonders reflektierter Mensch, der redet einfach. Und ähm.
Den dafür jahrelang fertig zu machen, da hat er irgendwann den Fehler gemacht da äh sich.
Adresse in diesem Video zu sagen und in einem YouTube Video zu sagen und zu sagen, kommt her, ich haue euch aufs Maul, aber weißt du, wenn irgendein Vollidiot im Internet sagt, kommt her, ne? Weißt du, was ich als erstes mache?
Das nicht? Weißt du so, ich ich es ist so,
Es sagt so viel über dich aus, wenn du dein wenn du dir zum Lebensinhalt irgendeinen Looser in Altschauerberg machst und das auch noch für den Kampf der Gerechten hältst.
Das ist wirklich faszinierend.
Ja, aber das ist jetzt nicht wenige Leute,
Ja, sondern es ist ein totaler Wahn geworden. Es ist so eine so eine Gruppe, die sich dann auch selbst bestärkt.
Wir sehen das ja immer wieder, ja, wo dann so eine eigene Sprache
aufgerufen wird mit so eigenen Begriffen und und Hauptsache man hat einen gemeinsamen Feind und dann kriegt man sich dann auch ausreichend gegenseitig legitimiert, dass das, was man da jetzt tut ja auch total
wichtig und gut und sinnvoll oder zumindest irgendwie okay oder nicht scheiße ist. Und das.
Das ist für mich das ist für mich das, was ich primär eigentlich immer wieder rausnehme, dass man sich auch bewusst machen muss.
So sehr wir jetzt hier auch irgendwie ethisch moralische Prinzipien hochhalten und uns irgendwie äh für unsere tolle Gesellschaft feiern und was wir doch irgendwie zivilisiert sind und modern und in die Zukunft gegangen sind.
Das einfach der der der Primatanteiler einfach irgendwie immer noch groß genug ist, wo einfach auf so ganz,
grundlegenden Dingen äh operiert wird und du dann mit mit 1000 geschichtlichen Einordnungen und,
philosophischen Einsichten einfach nirgendswo hinkommst, sondern im Zweifelsfall heißt es einfach äh alle alle drauf und Hauptsache ich.
Na ja, ich also.
Mir fällt mir fällt eigentlich nur der also es gibt ja solche Situationen im Kleinen ah findest du ja eigentlich in jeder Schulklasse.
Und auch da äh,
gehören sie bekämpft und auch da findest du regelmäßig so eine äh Täteropferumkehr, dass dann der,
Klassenlehrer sagt, hier pass mal auf so und so wenn es nicht so scheiße wärst, würden die anderen Kinder dich auch nicht hassen oder so was, ne? Kommt ja vor, so und ähm das.
Also das ist ein menschliches Phänomen hm von dem ich aber irgendwie eigentlich von einem Menschen, der alt genug ist mit einem Auto nach als Schauerberg zu fahren oder mit der Bahn.
Muss sich's in dem Alter rausgewachsen haben. Ne und ähm.
Also ich habe da wenig Verständnis für und ich denke mir das einzige, was an dieser Sache wirklich faszinierend ist,
Was für eine Energie und Ausdauer die entwickelt haben. Ja und wenn du jetzt mal überlegst, die hätten diese Energie und Ausdauer in irgendeine sinnvolle Tätigkeit,
gesetzt, ja? Die müssen sich ja auch fragen.
Habe ich in meinem Leben jetzt erreicht? Ich habe den ich habe den Rainer Winkler in Altschauerberg geärgert, weil der Scheiße im Internet gesagt hat. Was für ein, also ich meine, das muss da muss man doch auch selber irgendwann so ein bisschen höheren Anspruch noch entwickeln.
Sollte man einfach, aber ich glaube, das ist dann einfach auch nicht gefragt. Da da werden dann auch kleine Leben gelebt. Und da ist das dann irgendwie auch ein totales Highlight. Weil die anderen machen ja auch alle mit.
Darüber finden sich dann wieder neue Freundschaften.
Tolle Leute hast du kennengelernt OK die Drachenlord Sache in Ordnung aber wenn du dir überlegst was ich da für tolle Freundschaften entwickelt habe.
Die ganzen anderen, die ganzen anderen Vollidioten irgendwie sind jetzt alle meine Freunde irgendwie beim Drachengame Tinder habe ich irgendwie,
gleich irgendwie noch viele, viele neue Bekanntschaften äh geklickt, die sind auch alle genauso scheiße wie ich. Ist doch geil. Ja. Softs.
Wir finden es nicht gut und ich bin ehrlich gesagt ganz froh, dass mit dem äh Urteil, ich glaube es noch nicht rechtskräftig, weiß nicht, was ob da noch was kommt, aber wenn's mal so ausgeht, dann würde ich sagen.
Okay so, aber der Typ, der fährt jetzt halt irgendwie mit seinem Auto, äh der ist mehr oder weniger auf der Flucht. Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob der sich schon irgendwo
festgesetzt hat, aber äh natürlich sind diese ganzen Hater jetzt dabei, irgendwie online da open source intelligence zu machen und ihm irgendwie hinterherzuspionieren
Natürlich wird er sich in seinen ganzen YouTube-Videos auch ausreichend wieder verraten, was irgendwie Hinweise auf seinen Aufteilsort gibt. Also ich glaube, diese Sache wird.
Wird nicht gut enden. Das also erstens ist sie jetzt noch nicht vorbei,
und zweitens wird sie nicht gut enden. Ich will nicht sagen wie, aber habe nicht den Eindruck, dass das gut enden wird.
Er hat jetzt irgend so ein Video Musikvideo aber weißt du ich gucke mir das noch nicht mal an, muss ich auch äh zugeben. Also Videos.
Ich gucke mir das auch überhaupt gar nicht, also ich nehme daran null teil, sondern es ich nehme da immer nur wieder dran teil, wenn wenn's so Meldungen gibt und Presseberichte gibt, die sagen so, ja hier das ist in den letzten zwei Jahren passiert, es ist immer noch alles
scheiße mir dann denke so, oh Leute, ich lasse den Vogel doch einfach in Frieden, irgendwie sucht euch was anderes, wie du schon sagst, ne?
Tut euch zusammen und und und helft ukrainischen Flüchtlingen so mit eurer äh Aktivität, die ihr da an den Tag legt. Da habt ihr richtig was drauf könnt ihr euch.
Und dann werdet dann kriegt ihr ja also soll wirklich sagen was also boah habe was man was man da leisten kann, ja aber also und was Menschen da leisten, ich bin völlig baff, völlig irre, was da äh.
Ja, bei diesen Leuten geht's nur um um sie selbst, das ist das Problem. Also ich ich mache da einfach ein totale.
Ich glaube, die ich habe da noch ein bisschen Hoffnung, dass die die sind halt einfach auf irgendeine schiefe Bahn geraten und äh.
Schiefe Bahn geraten. Das ist einfach chronische Empathielosigkeit. Es ist einfach diese diese Speerspitze des des der Verechung.
Die da einfach zuschlägt so, dass einfach was für mich gut ist in dem Moment, ist gut.
Wenn ich da Spaß draus habe und mich mit allen anderen über Personen X lachen kann, dann ist das gut, weil ich lache ja.
Mir ist es doch egal, wie's anderen Leuten dabei geht. Bin ja nicht ich. Das ist,
glaube ich an an der Stelle einfach alles, was da zu holen ist. Mehr mehr ist aus diesen Hatern nicht rauszukratzen, wenn du die irgendwie auf einen Stuhl setzt und sagst erzähl mir mal was, was du Tolles in deinem Leben,
geschaffen hast oder was bedeutet würde bezweifeln, dass du da irgendwie nennenswert darüber hinauskommst? Ich ich.
Ja, ich äh also es mag sein, ähm ich äh habe ich gebe die Hoffnung nicht auf, dass die Leute auch noch mal irgendwie.
Ja auch von dem Ding runterkommen und und einfach auch was Sinnstiftenderes für sie selber finden. Also ich stelle mir das auch tatsächlich ziemlich frustrierend vor, das als Lebensinhalt zu haben, ne. Also da muss ja auch erstmal hinkommen,
Also überleg mal, was alles, also stell dir nur mal vor, was alles in deinem Leben nicht.
Sein, also was in deinem Leben nicht sein, alles weg sein müsste, dass du das als attraktive Handlungsoption entdeckst.
So weißt du? Also da musst du auch echt.
Lino ist du versuchst immer wieder aus deiner Position dich diesem zu nähern. Und ich sage dir einfach es ist das ist einfach,
Hoffnungsloser Fall. Du wirst von deiner Position da gibt's zwei weißt du hast du ein Labyrinth auf deinem den A4-Papier und willst von der einen Ecke zur anderen Ecke kommen, aber da sind einfach Wände dazwischen. Dann dann gibt's keinen Weg,
Kommst du nicht hin.
Weißt du doch gar nicht. Vielleicht mache ich irgendeinen anderen YouTuber fertig.
Ja. Macht auch einfach selber einen YouTube-Kanal auf.
Ich mache ich habe YouTube-Kanal. Guckt ja keiner. Vielleicht muss ich mal, ich einfach nicht.
Themen aufrufst, das ist doch das Problem.
So wir sind am Ende, oder?
Ja, sind wir ja total Leute. Ähm was soll man jetzt noch sagen?
Tschüss.
Ja sorry, dass wir eine Woche ausgelassen haben, ging nie anders. Äh wir sind bald wieder da und wir hören uns. Bis bald. Tschüss.
Bis bald, tschau tschau.